- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[upbeat music]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, we are going to
discuss your brain chemistry
and how to control and
optimize your brain chemistry
for all aspects of mental health,
physical health, and performance.
Many times before on the
Huberman Lab Podcast,
and frankly, every time I'm
a guest on another podcast,
I get questions about science
and science-based tools
for things like enhancing sleep,
enhancing focus,
enhancing creativity,
improving relationships,
getting over grief and on and on,
all of which are valid questions
and for which there are protocols
that are based in science
and that work the first
time and every time.
However far more important
than knowing a protocol
is understanding why a
given protocol works.
That's why I'm always
hammering on mechanism
and explaining the cells
and circuits and chemicals,
at least to some detail,
so that people can understand
not just what to do,
but why it works and therefore,
how to change a protocol
as their life circumstances change,
or as goals change.
Now today we are going to
go even a layer deeper.
We're going to explore the foundations
of your biology in your brain and body
that allow any protocol to work
because as it turns out,
all of the protocols out there,
whether or not it's a breathing protocol
or a supplement or a prescription drug
or an exercise routine,
they all tap into and leverage
a core set of just a few
biological mechanisms.
That's right,
beneath everything you
are able to do and feel
and indeed beneath every
protocol that allows you
to change for the better
and optimize your mental health,
physical health, and performance,
there's just a small subset of chemicals
that you're leveraging toward that change.
So today we are going to talk
about the four major
pillars of neurochemistry
that allow you to, for instance,
be focused when you want to focus,
that allow you to relax
when you need to relax and de-stress,
that allow you to optimize your sleep,
that allow you to optimize
your exercise routine
or to work through a pain
point in relationship
or in career or in your
relationship to yourself.
So what I can say for sure
is that by the end of this episode,
you will have a much richer understanding
about how your brain and nervous system
and indeed your entire body work.
And you'll have a much
firmer understanding
as to which protocols
and tools to reach for
given your particular goals in the moment,
in the day, across the
week, across the month,
across the year, and indeed
across your entire lifespan.
So what we're really going
for today are principles,
deeper understanding of why
any given protocol works
and we are also going to
discuss specific protocols.
Some of those protocols I've discussed
on previous episodes of
the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but I must say,
many of the protocols and
tools that I will discuss
are brand new and based on research
that I have not discussed at all,
simply because the research
papers came out only recently,
or these are papers that
I only recently unearthed.
In fact, I'm going to share
with you two recent studies
in a moment that are exceedingly important
for optimizing your sleep
and these are studies that, again,
I've never discussed
in any episode on sleep
or on any other podcast.
So by the end of today's episode,
you're going to have far more knowledge
about your biology and psychology
than you did at the start
and you'll be armed with many more tools
and most importantly,
principles so that you can navigate
not just the tools
presented on this podcast,
but in the vast landscape
of tools that are out there
for mental health, physical
health and performance.
The Huberman Lab Podcast
is proud to announce
that we've partnered with
Momentous supplements.
We've done that for several reasons.
First of all,
the quality of their
supplements is exceedingly high.
Second of all,
we wanted to have a location
where you could find
all of the supplements discussed
on the Huberman Lab Podcast
in one easy to find place.
You can now find that place
at livemomentous.com/huberman.
In addition, Momentous
supplements ship internationally,
something that a lot of
other supplement companies
simply do not do.
So that's terrific whether
or not you live in the US
or you live abroad.
Right now, not all of the supplements
that we discuss on the Huberman
Lab Podcast are listed,
but that catalog of supplements
is being expanded very rapidly
and a good number of them
that we've talked about,
some of the more prominent
ones for sleep and focus
and other aspects of
mental and physical health
are already there.
Again, you can find them at
livemomentous.com/huberman.
Every so often, I come across
a study or set of studies
that I get so excited about
that I start telling
everybody in my immediate life
and I insist on also sharing it with you,
the listeners of this podcast,
because I find the information
to be so incredibly
interesting and actionable.
The two studies that I'm going to discuss
both relate to sleep and sleep states
and how to access better sleep.
The first one was published
in the journal Cell Reports,
Cell Press journal, excellent journal.
And the title of this paper is
"Rapid and Reversible
Control of Human Metabolism
"by Individual Sleep States".
We will provide a link to this
study in the show captions.
The first author is Nora Nowak, N-O-W-A-K.
And basically what they
did is they measured
the different forms of
metabolism that occur
while humans sleep.
As far as I know,
this is one of the first
studies of this kind.
There are many studies of metabolism.
There are many studies of sleep.
This study focused on how
different states of sleep
such as rapid eye movement sleep,
which is associated with dreaming
and high emotional content dreams
versus slow wave sleep,
which tends to be more
focused on physical repair
of the body, more mundane dreams,
how those different states
of mind during sleep
relate to different aspects of metabolism
and what they found was
absolutely fascinating.
First of all,
they found that sleep states
regulate more than 50%,
half of all the metabolite
features detected
in human breath.
What does that mean?
Well, it turns out that you can figure out
what humans are
metabolizing in particular,
more lipids or more carbohydrate,
whether or not they're relying
more on glucose metabolism
based on the contents of their breath.
This is true during
waking and during sleep.
And this is what allowed them
to do these incredible measurements
of what's being metabolized during sleep.
They measured close to
2000 metabolites in breath,
every 10 seconds across
the entire night's sleep.
And what they found was that
there are major pathways
related to lipid metabolism,
fat metabolism,
or to carbohydrate metabolism
or other forms of metabolism
that are up or down regulated
as human beings transition
between slow wave sleep,
rapid eye movement sleep
and waking.
And you might say waking?
Well, yes, they also looked
as people fell asleep
and as they emerged from sleep.
And believe it or not every
so often during sleep,
you wake up, you didn't know this,
but you wake up in the
middle of the night,
you look around and you go back to sleep.
You're not aware of it
because you're still
in a rather sleep like state,
although you are awake.
What they found was that sleep
and the various states of sleep
regulated individual metabolic pathways.
They found for instance,
that the switch from sleep to wakefulness
reduces fatty acid oxidation.
So that means while you're asleep,
you're oxidating more fatty acids.
And as you wake up, that
becomes less the case.
And there's a switch in slow wave sleep
that increases fatty acid oxidation.
And there's this transition
from rapid eye movement sleep
to other aspects of sleep
that brings about things
like the so-called TCA cycle.
Some of you familiar with metabolism
will be familiar with the TCA cycle,
the so-called tricarboxylic acid cycle,
intermediates, that's fancy nerd speak
for specific aspects of
metabolism being regulated
during this rapid eye
movement sleep transition.
What does all this mean?
And how is this actionable?
Well, on many episodes of
the Huberman Lab Podcast
such as the master sleep episode
and the episode that we're going
into in further depth today,
we're going to talk about sleep
and how to optimize sleep.
It's been thought of,
but not really tamped down
that quality and depth of
sleep and duration of sleep
is important for metabolism
during the daytime.
And indeed that's the case.
If people are sleep deprived
or they're not sleeping enough,
things like glucose metabolism, et cetera,
get really disrupted during the daytime.
But what this current study shows
is that the metabolism that
you experience during sleep,
or to be more specific,
the range of different types of metabolism
that you experience during sleep
may serve to tune up
or to ensure that the
specific aspects of metabolism
that you require during
wakefulness are working properly.
In addition to that,
this study clearly shows
that getting enough sleep
allows you to transition
through all the various
forms of metabolism
and use all those different forms
of metabolites during sleep
in a way that's immensely beneficial
for the systems of your brain and body.
So the take home message here is that,
as the author state,
sleep and experiencing the
different states of sleep,
slow wave sleep early in
the night, predominantly,
plus rapid eye movement sleep
toward the end of the night
is extremely important for
optimizing metabolic circuits
for human performance and health.
In other words, by not getting
sufficient duration sleep,
you're not allowing your body
and brain to transition through
all the different aspects
of fuel utilization
and you're not teaching
your brain and body
how to use similar types of
fuels during wakefulness.
So again, all of this points to the fact
that we need to be
getting sufficient quality
and duration of sleep.
So if you're sleep deprived,
even by an hour or so,
you're going to get far less
rapid eye movement sleep
because rapid eye movement
sleep is what occurs
toward the end of a sleep night.
During the early part of the night,
far more slow wave sleep.
In getting less rapid eye movement sleep,
we know it makes you
more emotionally labile,
but now we know it's also
going to alter certain forms
of glucose metabolism
during the night
and during wakefulness.
So that all underscores
the need to get sleep.
But then the question is
how to get enough sleep
and how to make sure you get
into all these different sleep states.
And this is particularly important
for you so-called night owls.
There's a lot of controversy out there
as to whether or not different
so-called chronotypes exist,
that is people who just
naturally or genetically
want to be an early bird,
wake up early and go to bed early.
So these people that wake up at 4:00 AM
and would be most comfortable going to bed
by seven or 8:00 PM or 9:00 PM.
Then they are so called night owls,
people that would feel
best or tend to feel best
when they go to sleep at 1:00
AM, 2:00 AM, even 3:00 AM,
and like to wake up
later 8:00, 9:00, 10:00,
or even 11:00 AM or noon.
And then of course,
most people go to sleep somewhere
between 10:00 PM and midnight
and wake up somewhere
between 5:00 AM and 7:00 AM,
or I suppose more typically
6:00 AM and 8:00 AM.
Now whether or not real chronotypes exist
or whether or not people
simply select schedules
for sleep and wakefulness that they like
because of their social schedules
or the activities they enjoy.
For instance, some people
like to really go out,
they like to go out dancing or hear music,
or spend time in venues that
are only open late at night,
and don't even open until noon or after.
Other people like myself
rarely go out at night
but I like to get up early.
I like to exercise.
I like to see the sunrise, et cetera.
So I don't know if I'm a morning person
or an evening person.
I just know the things I enjoy
tend to happen in the
early part of the day.
And the things that I
don't enjoy quite as much
tend to happen late at night.
Regardless of whether or not
there are real genetic propensities
to be a night owl or an early bird
or a sort of typical person
right there in the middle,
it's very important that people
have some control over
their sleep schedule
and even more important,
that people are able to
get sufficient amount
of REM sleep and slow wave sleep,
for many reasons,
but including the reasons I discussed
in the previous study
related to metabolism.
I'm very excited, therefore,
about a study that came
out in sleep medicine.
This was a few years ago, but
somehow I missed this one.
It was published in 2019.
And the title of this article is
"Resetting the Late Timing of 'Night Owls'
"Has a Positive Impact on Mental Health,
"Physical Health and Performance".
This is a study done in humans,
focusing specifically on people
that like to stay up late and sleep in,
but who desire to be able
to get up and feel alert
in order to go to work or study
and they want to go to
sleep a bit earlier.
And so there are a lot of questions
embedded in this study in particular,
whether or not people can
actually shift their schedule
by a few hours or more.
Some people out there contend
that if you're a night owl,
that's just going to be impossible
or very, very challenging to do.
Turns out it's not impossible
and it's not even that challenging to do
provided you do the right things.
Just a brief overview of the study
and then I'll give you the key takeaways.
It was a randomized control trial.
It involved a number of different people,
both male and female.
And what they did was they
used non-pharmacological,
practical interventions
in a real world setting,
here I'm paraphrasing.
They used targeted light exposure.
They used consistent sleep, wake times.
They used fixed meal times,
caffeine intake and exercise.
And this is one of the reasons
I love this study so much
because I've done episodes
where I've talked about temperature,
exercise, feeding, and most importantly,
light exposure as a way to control
and shift your sleep wake cycles,
your so-called circadian
timing and entrainment.
What did they find?
Well, they found "Significant improvements
"in terms of mood so far
less depression and stress",
subjectively measured,
"as well as improved
cognitive performance",
that was objectively measured.
So improved reaction times,
improved physical grip strength,
which is actually a measure
not just of strength per se,
but also of nervous system function
and a number of things
that people could do
in order to optimize their morning hours,
even though they were
night owls previously.
What did they have people do?
Well, I'm going to just
going to list this off
sort of rapid fire succession.
Then we'll provide a link to the study
if you want to learn more.
First of all, they told participants
to try and wake up two to three hours
before their typical wake up time,
two to three hours.
That seems brutal to me
and probably seems brutal to you
if you're somebody who
typically wakes up at 10:00 AM
to try and get up at eight
or even 7:00 AM consistently,
but they were also asked to maximize
outdoor light exposure during the mornings
for reasons that if you've
listened to this podcast before,
if you've heard me talk about before,
you know, that I'm
constantly talking about,
I'll probably go into the grave shouting,
please get as much light exposure
from sunlight early in the day as possible
because it sets in motion
a huge number of things
that are beneficial
for your mental health
and physical health,
including dopamine production,
timing melatonin production correctly,
reducing cortisol peaks late in the day,
et cetera, et cetera.
So they asked them to get a
lot of outdoor light exposure.
They didn't give them a specific amount.
What they said,
maximize outdoor light
exposure during the mornings,
the time before noon.
And again, they had them
waking up two to three hours
before their habitual wake up time.
They were also told,
and this is very important
if you're going to shift
your schedule earlier,
to try and keep sleep wake times fixed
between their work days
and their weekends.
So not sleeping in on the weekends
or not having any sleep in days,
regardless of how well they
slept the night before.
How fixed?
Within 15 to 30 minutes of
their pre-designated time.
So if they were waking up
at seven o'clock one day,
they set their alarm and they
made sure they got out of bed
at seven o'clock every day
plus or minus 30 minutes,
but never later than 7:30,
never earlier than 6:30.
Participants were also
asked to try and go to sleep
two to three hours before
their habitual bedtime.
So again, these are people
that want to stay up late,
like 11:00 PM, perhaps,
but even as late as 1:00 AM or 2:00 AM.
And now they are asked to go to sleep
two to three hours before
their habitual bedtime
and to wake up two to three hours earlier,
as I mentioned earlier.
They were also told,
and I love this because it
fits with many of the things
we've talked about on this podcast before,
to try and limit light
exposure during the evenings,
dim the lights or limit
altogether artificial lights.
Lot of reasons for that,
I covered that in the
Master Sleep episode,
I covered that in the Optimized
Health Using Light episode.
You can find those at HubermanLab.com.
They're asking them to do that here.
And they asked participants
to keep a regular schedule
for their daily meals,
not eating on the hour consistently,
you know, at 9:00 AM,
noon, 3:00 PM, exactly.
But within again, about 15 to 30 minutes,
they're always eating at the same times.
That was also important.
And again, that's because
we have these so-called
food in trained circadian clocks.
When you eat, tells your
body when to be alert
and when you're not
eating, when to be asleep.
And they were told to
not drink any caffeine
after 3:00 PM in the afternoon.
Another theme that we've
talked about on this podcast.
They were also told not to
take naps after 4:00 PM.
Naps are an interesting feature
of the sleep wake cycle.
To be very brief about this
and to pull from the episode
that I did with world sleep expert
from the University of
California Berkeley, Matt Walker,
naps are great for many people,
but don't nap if it interferes
with your nighttime sleep.
And in this study, they told
them don't nap after 4:00 PM.
And if you are a napper, don't
nap for more than 90 minutes.
10 minute naps are fine.
20 minute naps are fine.
Zero minute naps are fine,
but don't nap for more than 90 minutes.
And don't nap after 4:00 PM.
And to exercise during the morning.
Now this one can be a bit controversial
because I know a lot of the PTs out there
and a lot of the online, you know,
gym rats and people who,
and runners too, for that matter,
will say, well according to
body temperature and research,
it's best to exercise in the afternoon.
Look, it's better to exercise sometime
as opposed to no time,
but if you're focused on how
to shift your schedule earlier,
meaning get up earlier
and go to sleep earlier,
this study had people exercise
in the early part of the day,
certainly before 2:00 PM
and ideally before noon.
So again, this is a really important study
because it combines a lot
of different variables
to arrive at this very impressive shift
where people can get up
two to three hours earlier
and then pretty
consistently and reflexively
start going to bed two
to three hours earlier,
feeling more alert during the day,
again, improvements in
cognitive performance,
mood and physical performance,
grip, strength, et cetera.
Very few studies are able to
or are willing to tackle so many variables
and combine them in one study.
This paper, I think, does a
marvelous job of doing this
and is incorporating
things that individually,
each have some support for them
in animal studies and
previous human studies.
But as far as I know,
this is one of the few studies
that really combines all
these different features
in one place,
eating times, keeping those consistent,
getting maximal sunlight
exposure earlier in the day,
getting up at a consistent time,
going to sleep at a
consistent time and on and on.
It's a really marvelous
study for that reason.
And I think for any of
you that are night owls
and any of you that want to
reinforce your early waking
and early to bed times,
and I think for most all of you
who fall into that general middle category
of tend to go to sleep somewhere
between 10:00 PM and midnight,
'cause that's most people
and tend to wake up sometime
between 6:00 AM and 8:00 AM,
well, maybe you want to
become more of an early riser
or maybe you're going to travel
or the seasons are changing
and you want to shift your time
or you have a new job, et cetera,
or something that's actually very common
in terms of relationship struggle.
You want to match your wake sleep times,
or maybe you want to offset
your wake sleep times
from a significant other,
these sorts of approaches
that I described here
and that are supported
by the data in this paper
are absolutely powerful
and science supported.
And I'm certain that if
you were to apply them,
that you would see
essentially the same effects
that were observed here.
Before we begin,
I'd like to emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is however, part of
my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Athletic
Greens now called AG1.
AG1 is an all-in-one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink
that also includes adaptogens
and digestive enzymes for health.
Now the probiotics are
particularly important to me
because there is now a wealth of data
showing that our gut microbiome,
that is trillions of little microbacteria
that are good for us,
impact our immune system, our hormones,
and the so-called gut brain access,
the connections between
our gut and our brain
that go in both directions,
gut to brain and brain to gut,
that control things like our mood,
our ability to think clearly
and focus and overall brain health.
And with AG1, I'm able to
optimize that gut brain access
through the probiotics and
the vitamins, minerals,
adaptogens and digestive enzymes,
support a number of other things
that relate to immediate
and long-term health.
In fact, anytime people ask me,
what's the one supplement
they should take,
I say AG1 Athletic Greens,
because it's going to
cover all of your bases
to the greatest degree.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They'll give you five free travel packs
that make it easy to mix up
AG1 while you're on the road.
And they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2.
Vitamin D3 and K2 are important
for cardiovascular function
and calcium regulation,
and a number of other
important aspects of health.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim that special offer
of the five free travel packs
and the year supply of vitamin D3 K2.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
And frankly, I'm not a big
fan of the word nootropics.
I've said that on various
podcasts and on social media posts
and the reason I'm not a
fan of the word nootropics
is it means smart drugs,
but as a neuroscientist,
I know that we don't have
circuits in the brain
or chemicals in the brain for being smart.
We have circuits in the brain for focus
and for task switching and for creativity.
And oftentimes, those circuits
differ from one another,
although they collaborate to create things
that we think of as intelligence
or focus or creativity, et cetera.
Thesis understands this
and for that reason
has developed custom nootropics
that are matched to your particular goals
and to your particular biology.
They give you the opportunity
to try several different blends
over the course of a month
and discover which ones work best for you
and which ones don't.
In addition to that personalization,
they take it a step further
by offering free
consultations with a coach
to help you optimize your experience
and dial in your perfect formulas.
I've be using Thesis for
about eight months now
and I can confidently
say that their nootropics
are the best that I've ever used.
My go-to formula is the Clarity formula
or the Motivation formula
when I'm going to work or work out,
meaning I'm going to do
focus cognitive work,
or I'm going to exercise.
I also like their Energy
formula prior to exercise.
To get your own personalized
nootropic starter kit,
go online to takethesis.com/huberman.
You can take a three minute
quiz that will help match you
to the best custom
nootropics to start with.
And Thesis will send you
four different formulas
to try in that first month.
Again, that's takethesis.com/huberman
and use the code Huberman at checkout
to get 10% off your first order.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from
your blood and your DNA
to help you better understand your body
and help you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason
that many of the things
that impact your immediate
and long-term health
can only be measured from
a quality blood test.
And nowadays with the
advent of modern DNA test,
you can also get insight
into, for instance,
what is your biological age
and how does that compare
to your chronological age?
And of course, your biological age
is really the one that matters.
With InsideTracker, there's
an additional advantage
over other blood tests and DNA tests.
And that is with many blood
tests and DNA tests out there,
you get information back about
hormones, lipids, et cetera,
but you don't know what to
do with that information.
With InsideTracker,
they have a very simple,
easy to use personalized platform
that tells you what sorts of changes
to make in your nutrition,
possible changes to supplementation,
behavioral changes, et cetera,
that will allow you to bring the numbers
related to your hormones
and your lipids, et cetera,
into the ranges that are
optimal for your mental health,
physical health and performance goals.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker
you can go to insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
That's insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Let's talk about how to optimize
and indeed how to control
your brain chemistry
for a sake of health and performance.
Now in order to do that,
we all need to be on the same page
about some basic facts.
Some of those basic facts
involve learning some basic biology.
And I promise that even if
you don't have a biology
or chemistry background,
everything I'm about to
say should be accessible
and clear to you.
The important thing to know
is that your brain and your spinal cord
and the rest of your
so-called nervous system
control all the organs of your body
and that all the organs
of your body feed back,
meaning they communicate through
chemicals and other means,
to your nervous system.
Now your nervous system plays
a particularly important role
in generating everything from sleep
to wakefulness, creativity,
stress, calm, et cetera,
by way of a particular type
of cell-cell interaction.
And that's called synaptic communication.
What is synaptic communication?
Well, in order to understand that
let's dial back a little bit further
and try and understand for a moment
what makes up your nervous system.
In its simplest form,
your nervous system is made of nerve cells
that we call neurons.
Neurons communicate with one
another through chemicals.
They release certain chemicals
that make other neurons
more or less likely to
be electrically active.
What do we mean by electrically active?
We mean,
as it sounds,
electricity passing down through cells
and then literally causing
electricity in other cells.
The simplest way to think about this
is maybe when you were a
kid or maybe even still now,
you would wear socks and
you'd shuffle along the floor
to generate some static electricity,
and then you'd touch
someone [playful whirring]
and you'd shock them with your finger.
I'm a younger brother
so I'd occasionally do that to my sister.
I had friends, we would
do that to one another.
I know it's kind of silly and childish,
yet, it illustrates the principle
that we can generate
electricity and pass electricity
to other beings or in the case of neurons,
from one neuron to the next.
The way neurons do that,
is that in between the neurons,
they're little spaces,
those little spaces are called synapses
and neurons literally vomit,
well, they don't literally vomit,
but they release little packets
of so-called transmitter chemical
into that space we call a synapse.
It travels across the synapse.
It attaches to the cell on the other side,
the other neuron.
And then depending on
what that chemical is,
it either makes that next
neuron more electrically active
or less electrically active,
so called excitation,
it either excites the next neuron
to be electrically active also,
or it inhibits, it
prevents the next neuron
from being electrically active.
So again, very simply,
we have nerve cells that
communicate with one another
through electricity and chemicals
that inspire that electricity
and the little gaps between
neurons are called synapses.
If you can understand that,
I'm certain you can make it
through the rest of the episode
and that you'll get all the
depth and important detail
that you need to know.
But I want to go just a little bit further
and explain that neurons
don't just talk one-to-one.
There are trillions of
neurons in your nervous system
that allow you to be happy, to be in love,
to be sad, to be in grief,
to remember things and so on.
And what you do at any moment,
what you feel and what you think
relates to which so-called
neural circuits are active.
So a lot of times we
think about brain areas
and we've all seen these
pictures of the brain
where, you know, someone
was in a fMRI scanner,
or they were in a brain
scanner of some sort,
and they saw a picture of something
and a certain area of the
brain lights up as it's called.
That lighting up of the
brain really reflects
the activity of hundreds,
if not thousands,
maybe even millions of
neurons in that region.
Those images of brain areas lighting up
and indeed talking about
brain areas lighting up,
can be a little bit or a lot misleading
because in fact, no single brain area
controls any one single perception
or behavior or feeling state.
Rather, we have so-called neuro circuits,
chains of neurons,
chains of specific neurons that is,
that create different states of mind
that lead to specific behaviors
that lead to specific emotional states.
And those neural circuits are made up
of lots of different
brain areas that light up
in particular sequences.
And when I say light up, excuse me,
what I mean is that particular
brain areas either excite
or prevent the excitation,
that is they inhibit other brain areas
in a particular sequence.
Much like keys on a piano
played in a particular sequence,
makes up a particular song,
particular brain areas
activated or made silent
in a particular sequence
leads to a particular behavior
like getting up out of a chair
or a particular feeling state
like being particularly happy
one day when you wake up
or particularly depressed,
whether or not that depression
is caused by a life event
or whether not it arises spontaneously.
So we have neurons, we have synapses
and we have neural circuits.
And vitally important is the fact that
which neural circuits are active
and which neural circuits
are likely to be less active
at any given moment,
depends on two major
categories of chemicals.
It depends on hormones
and it depends on
so-called neuromodulators.
Now we're mainly going to
focus on neuromodulators today
because those are the things
that if you can learn to control them,
and indeed there are
tools to control them,
then you can control which neural circuits
are more likely or less
likely to be active
in you at any given moment.
And in doing so,
you can control whether or not
you are going to be alert
and focused or deeply asleep.
You can control whether or not
you are going to be in a creative state
or whether or not you're
going to be in a state of mind
more fit, more capable that is
of doing focused work or math
or more so-called linear types of work
where there's a correct answer.
There's a specific thing to follow
and you're simply going to
plug and chug as it were
through a particular set of steps
in order to accomplish something.
Or for instance,
whether or not you're going
to be in a more relaxed
and creative state where
you're thinking about new ideas
or new ideas just seem to be
spontaneously coming to mind.
All of that can be controlled
to a considerable extent
by leveraging these
so-called neuromodulators.
What are neuromodulators?
Neuromodulators are particular chemicals
that make it likely
that certain neuro circuits
will be active and not others.
And the four neuromodulators
that we're going to talk about today
that are of the utmost
importance for your goals
are dopamine,
epinephrine also called adrenaline,
serotonin and acetylcholine.
That's dopamine, epinephrine,
Today, I'm going to teach you
how each of those different categories
of neuromodulators work
and the things that you can do
to control those neuromodulators,
that is increase them or decrease them
through behavioral tools
and supplementation,
in ways that allow you to access
the brain and body states that you want
at the times that you want.
Just very quickly.
I want to talk about how
neuromodulators are able to work,
regardless of whether or not it's dopamine
or serotonin or epinephrine, et cetera.
There are many features of
how neuromodulators work,
but for sake of today's discussion,
we only need to focus on
two of those features.
And those are fast-acting features
and longer slower features
or what we call baseline features.
What am I talking about when
I say faster or baseline?
Well, consider that at any given moment,
whether or not you're asleep or awake,
whether or not it's morning
or afternoon or night,
you have some amount of dopamine
being released in your brain and body,
some amount of serotonin,
some amount of epinephrine
and some amount of acetylcholine.
It is rarely, if ever the case,
that you have zero
dopamine or zero serotonin.
You know, so often we hear about someone
being dopamine depleted
or these days, you hear
a lot about that anyways.
Or you'll hear that people's
serotonin is bottomed out.
In reality, none of these neuromodulators
ever disappear completely,
but they tend to be
present at different levels
or different relative levels.
Another important thing to point out
is that they don't work alone.
In fact, as you'll soon learn,
dopamine and epinephrine are close cousins
that collaborate in
terms of creating states
of focus and motivation, for instance,
or in creating states of energy
and the pursuit of particular goals.
When I say they're close cousins,
what I mean is that they tend to impact
some of the same neural circuits.
And believe it or not,
dopamine and epinephrine
are chemically related, too.
I'll just tell you right now
that epinephrine is actually
derived from dopamine,
chemically epinephrine,
that is adrenaline,
is made from the molecule dopamine.
Now dopamine and serotonin
can also work together
to impact certain circuits in the brain.
But in large part,
they operate on separate circuits.
And acetylcholine,
which you'll soon learn is involved
in states of focus and
can actually open up,
it can literally create states in the mind
in which your brain is more plastic
and able to change and learn more quickly.
Well, acetylcholine
can do that on its own,
but rarely does it do it on its own.
More typically, it gets assistance
from some of the other neuromodulators.
Now that might seem like
it complicates the picture,
but it actually makes
the picture far simpler
because what we can say for sure
is that the fast actions of dopamine
or the fast actions of epinephrine,
serotonin or acetylcholine
are actions that occur on the
order of seconds or minutes
or up to about an hour or so.
Whereas the slower actions
of those neuromodulators
tend to occur on the order of
hours, days, or even weeks.
Now perhaps surprisingly,
I'd like to focus on the slow actions
of the neuromodulators first,
because those slow actions
of the neuromodulators
are happening in you and in
me and in everyone right now,
and they set the backdrop,
the context in which the various tools
to manipulate dopamine,
epinephrine, serotonin,
or acetylcholine will work.
What do I mean by the context
or the backdrop or the baseline?
Well, it's fair to say that most people
are awake during the
daytime and asleep at night.
I do realize that there are people
who are going to be doing shift work
or they're raising young children,
or that might have a sick person at home
that they're tending to, et cetera,
or even have insomnia,
they're tending to them.
So schedules of sleep and
wakefulness will vary,
but in general, everybody,
regardless of whether
or not you're nocturnal
or you're, so-called, diurnal,
your awake during the day,
pretty much everybody
follows a schedule in which
from zero to nine hours after waking,
that is from the time you wake up
until about nine hours later,
the neuromodulators,
dopamine and epinephrine,
tend to be at their highest
levels that they will be
at any point in the 24-hour period,
in any period of the day.
So we can call this
zero to nine hour period
phase one of the day, just for simplicity.
And I've referred to this
before in a previous episode,
but not in this exact context.
From nine to about 16 hours is
what we would call phase two.
And that's when dopamine
and epinephrine levels
tend to subside a bit
compared to the earlier
phase one part of the day
and serotonin levels start to increase.
And then phase three of the 24-hour cycle,
which is from about,
and again about the zero approximates,
from about 17 hours after waking
until about 24 hours after waking
is phase three of the day.
And during that time,
there is chaos in terms of which
neuromodulators are most
present in the brain.
And by chaos, what I mean
is that during sleep,
you have incredible peaks in acetylcholine
and drops in acetylcholine.
You have incredible peaks in dopamine
and drops in dopamine.
You have incredible peaks in serotonin
and drops in serotonin.
Most often, you are not going to see
much if any release of
epinephrine, adrenaline,
and that's because epinephrine,
also called adrenaline,
tends to wake us up and put
us into action mode behaviors
and that's simply not
happening during sleep.
But for the other three neuromodulators,
across the night,
it's sort of chaos.
You've got peaks and
drops and peaks and drops
in different combinations
than you would ever see in wakefulness.
And this plays important
roles in dreaming,
important roles
in some of the reparative
functions of sleep.
The point is that during that phase three,
the levels of neuromodulators
are all over the place,
but it's not random, right?
I say it's chaos, but it's organized
according to the specific
reparative goals of sleep,
the specific metabolic
roles of sleep, et cetera.
We're not going to focus too
much on phase three today
because phase three of the 24-hour cycle,
that 17 to 24-hour period,
is one in which you ought
to be deeply asleep,
whether or not you're
nocturnal or diurnal, right?
17 hours after waking,
you ought to be asleep.
And there are a lot of
episodes of this podcast.
And indeed, today, I started talking about
two particular studies related to sleep,
and there are a lot of tools
to enhance sleep, et cetera.
And of course there are
things that you can do
in the late portion of
phase two of the day
in order to enhance your transition time
into and depth of sleep.
But you can't really do
much during sleep, right?
You're not taking supplements.
You're not doing breathing practices.
There are things to fall back asleep,
but you're not really
doing much during sleep.
So we're mainly going to focus
on what we're calling
phase one and phase two.
Phase one, being this dopamine
epinephrine dominated phase of our day.
And phase two being this more serotonergic
or serotonin dominated portion of the day.
And then you might say,
well, what about acetylcholine?
You forgot about acetylcholine?
Well, we didn't forget
about acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine is under control
more in terms of what
we happen to be doing
at any given moment,
whether or not we're
focusing or not focusing,
learning or not learning.
And here I'm referring to acetylcholine
specifically in the context
of the brain and thinking,
because as some of you
are probably shouting out there, right,
if you're an exercise physiologist
or you know anything about how
the brain controls movement,
acetylcholine is used at the
nerve to muscle synapse, right?
So neurons don't just control
other neurons electrically.
The way you are able to move in fact
is because neurons are controlling
the electric activity of muscles,
literally the contraction
of muscle fibers,
and that control is exerted
through the release of acetylcholine.
So acetylcholine is working
at muscles, as well,
but we're not focused on that today.
We're focused on what we can do
during phase one of the day
and what we can do during
phase two of the day
to control the specific neuromodulators,
dopamine, epinephrine,
serotonin, and acetylcholine,
toward particular end goals.
And as I've been harping
on for the last five
or 10 minutes or so,
it is important to understand
that in the early phase
one part of the day,
again, zero to nine hours,
dopamine and epinephrine already
dominate the neuromodulator landscape.
That is they are already elevated
and then they will taper off in phase two.
Whereas in phase two of the day,
serotonin tends to dominate
more than dopamine and epinephrine.
And so if you think about that,
what it means is that if your goal
is to increase serotonin
in order to get some particular effect
on your mental performance
or physical performance or health,
or if your goal is to increase
your dopamine or epinephrine,
to get some particular
effect on your mental health,
physical performance, et cetera,
well, then you need to consider
what the background level of dopamine
or epinephrine or serotonin happens to be
because in doing so,
you will know which tool to select
and how hard you need to
push on that tool, right?
If your levels of dopamine are
already riding pretty high,
because it's the early part of the day,
well then it doesn't take a whole lot more
to get dopamine to a
level in which it can,
for instance, change
your level of motivation.
Whereas if you are in
the late part of the day,
let's say eight or 9:00 PM,
and you have a lot of serotonin
swimming around in your system
and you really need to
be focused and alert,
well, you can do that by
leveraging the dopamine
and epinephrine system
and indeed the acetylcholine system too,
but you're going to
have to resort to tools
that can do that far more potently
and that can do that in
a much more sustained way
if you're going to access
the state that you want.
So again, it's really
important to understand
what the backdrop of
these neuromodulators is,
the so-called baseline
and that they vary across the day
if you are going to be
able to leverage tools
to optimize your brain chemistry.
Anyone that tells you do this protocol
in order to increase your dopamine,
do this protocol,
or take this supplement to
increase your serotonin,
they can be telling
you the absolute truth,
but if you don't consider the backdrop
over which that supplement
or behavior is going to have its effect,
well, then you can't really
predict the effect it will have.
But if you can understand these
backdrop baseline elements
to how neuromodulators work,
well, then you're in a terrific position
to leverage the best tools
in the immediate and short-term
and that is on the order of
seconds, minutes and hours.
Before we dive into the more pointed,
directed effects of specific
tools on neuromodulators,
I'd like to just briefly mention hormones
because they are also important
for understanding the
background and the context
and these baseline levels
of neuromodulators.
Now here, I'm going to paint
with a bit of a broad brush,
but what I will say is accurate,
even though it might not be exhaustive.
What I mean by that is everything
I'm about to say is true,
but it doesn't cover
every example in detail
and nuanced possibility out there.
Hormones have many different
effects on the brain and body
and not unlike neuromodulators,
some of those effects are very fast.
Some of them are very slow.
In fact, certain hormones,
for instance, the steroid hormones,
like estrogen and like testosterone
and corticosteroids
and here, of course,
I'm referring to the steroid
hormones for what they are.
They are indeed steroid hormones,
but I'm not talking about steroids
that people inject for sports performance
or for physical augmentation.
I'm talking about the steroid hormones
that you make naturally
because indeed you make these naturally.
Well, the steroid hormones
can actually control gene expression.
They can change the identity of cells
and the genes and proteins
that cells express.
This is why during puberty, for instance,
testosterone and estrogen
are released into the body,
growth hormone is released into the body
and bodies and voices and personalities
and brains change tremendously
because literally there
is a transformation
of the breast tissue,
of the testicular tissue,
of the ovarian tissue, of
the bones, of the muscles,
of the tissues and cells
that control hair growth.
Gene expression changes
in all those cell types.
And the child becomes an adolescent,
becomes a young adult, right?
That's what puberty really is.
In fact, puberty is perhaps
the most dramatic transformation
that we go through
in our entire lifespan
in terms of our aging,
'cause indeed it reflects a very rapid,
I should mention, period of aging
and transformation of
the identity of cells.
So steroid hormones and other hormones
can have very slow long-lasting
actions in that way.
They can also have very fast actions.
So for instance,
adrenaline, epinephrine,
released from the adrenal glands
can immediately make
your heart beat faster,
can immediately change the circumference
of your blood vessels and
arteries and capillaries
and change the way blood flows.
It can change the way you
see the world, literally.
It does change the way you see the world
through your visual system.
And that all happens on the order
of hundreds of milliseconds or seconds,
these are extremely fast actions.
Corticosteroid also can have
fast actions and slow actions.
But since this isn't a
discussion about hormones per se,
and we've done entire episodes
like the Optimize Testosterone
and Estrogen episode.
You can find that at HubermanLab.com.
Or the interview with the
incredibly knowledgeable
and clear and
really wonderful tutor of
actionable information,
Dr. Kyle Gillette, who
is also on this podcast,
you can learn a lot about hormones there.
Today, we want to think about hormones
as they relate to these neuromodulators,
the dopamine, serotonin,
epinephrine and acetylcholine,
and in general,
testosterone tends to collaborate with
and increase the action of dopamine.
That's not always the
case, but in general,
when testosterone goes
up, dopamine goes up
and sometimes even vice versa.
When dopamine goes up, testosterone go up.
And this is true for both
males and for females.
In general, when corticosteroids
like cortisol and some related
steroid hormones increase,
epinephrine levels go up.
And in general, when
hormones like oxytocin
or prolactin are increased,
levels of serotonin go up.
We can't draw a direct link
between any one hormone
system and acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine kind of sits off
in a category of its own in that way.
But again, in general,
testosterone and dopamine
tend to collaborate in the same direction.
Cortisol and epinephrine
tend to collaborate
in the same direction.
Oxytocin and prolactin,
which are hormones,
and serotonin tend to collaborate
in the same direction.
And then we have poor
old, lonely acetylcholine
off on its own, but it's
not poor and lonely.
It actually has incredibly
potent effects on its own.
So it's really that it
just doesn't mean much help
from the hormone systems
or at least not the
steroid hormone systems
in order to have its tremendous effects.
Now a lot of what people think about
and will do when trying
to improve mental health
and physical health
is they will try and increase
or decrease certain categories of hormones
of the sort that I mentioned,
testosterone, estrogen,
oxytocin, and prolactin, so on.
But oftentimes, the effects
of those manipulations
in hormones that are
going to be most salient
are not going to be due
to the direct effects
of those hormones.
Sometimes it could be.
But oftentimes it's going
to be due to their effects
on the brain and nervous system
by way of how those hormones
impact neuromodulators.
So for instance,
there are various things
that people can do,
both men and women,
to increase their
testosterone and estrogen
in the appropriate ratios.
I talked about one such
approach in a previous episode,
and that is to get sunlight
onto a large portion
of one's skin each day.
Believe it or not, this actually works.
And it works because your skin
is actually an endocrine organ,
a hormone secreting organ.
It's a beautiful study.
I've covered it on this podcast before.
We will provide a link
to this study again,
but it had people spend
at least 20 minutes or so,
closer to 30 minutes, each day,
trying to maximize sunlight exposure
to as much of their skin as they could
in terms of still
maintaining decent exposure,
meaning not over exposing
themselves in a cultural way,
meaning wearing enough
clothes that they were decent,
but still getting a lot of sun exposure,
a couple of times per week or more.
What they found was that
people's testosterone
and estrogen levels went up.
Feelings of well-being went up.
Feelings of well, or I should
say increases in libido
were observed, as well.
They subjectively reported
more passion, et cetera,
testosterone and estrogen
did indeed both go up.
And again, I want to highlight
that increases in estrogen,
not just testosterone,
are related to increases in
libido in both men and women.
This is why you never want
to crush your estrogen down to zero,
whether or not you're male or female,
if you want to maintain
some sort of healthy libido
and general feelings of
well-being, unrelated to libido.
Well, many of those effects
we know are not due to direct effects
of testosterone and estrogen,
but rather are due to the effects
of testosterone and estrogen
on the neuromodulators,
dopamine and serotonin,
because much of libido
and feelings of well-being
and feelings of relaxation,
but also desire, motivation, et cetera,
originate because of the
activation of neural circuits
that dopamine controls and promotes
and that serotonin promote and control.
So this is very important to understand
as we move toward more specific discussion
of the chemicals that
we call neuromodulators,
because hormones are controlling
those neuromodulators
in a very slow modulatory way.
So yes, I said it,
hormones modulate neuromodulators.
I sort of said it twice on purpose.
And this is a dramatic and potent effect.
So I'll just give you one more example.
The hormone prolactin
tends to be antagonistic.
It tends to reduce amounts of dopamine
or at least when
prolactin levels are high,
dopamine levels tend to be lower.
You observe this after
the birth of a new child,
you observe this post
coitally after mating,
in all species, humans and animals.
When prolactin is elevated,
serotonin tends to be elevated.
And when prolactin is elevated,
levels of dopamine and
the effects of dopamine
tend to subside.
Now as I move toward explaining
what each of the four categories
of neuromodulators do,
this will start to make
more and more sense
as to why this would be.
I always say I wasn't
consulted in the design phase,
meaning I didn't design these circuits.
And if anyone tells you that they did,
you should back away quickly
because none of us design these circuits.
This is the way that evolution
and nature created these systems.
And they tend to work in
a bit of a seesaw fashion,
prolactin up, dopamine down, right?
Dopamine up, prolactin down.
In general, that is the way they work.
So if we are to take a
look at how each of these
neuromodulator systems
functions on its own,
while understanding that
they never truly function on their own,
we can start to really make sense
of the landscape of tools
that are available to us
and which tools are going to
be most powerful to select
if our goal is for instance, to be focused
or if our goal is to be less stressed
or if our goal is to be highly motivated
and highly focused for sake of learning.
All of that is indeed possible
if you understand these
four neuromodulators
and you understand that
while there are many tools
ranging from pharmacologic to behavioral
that can tap into these
neuromodulator systems,
that can kind of press
on the gas of dopamine,
pull back on serotonin and so on,
but that there are particular tools,
both behavioral and supplementation-based,
and to some extent,
prescription drug based, too,
and we'll touch on a few of those.
If you understand that and why they work,
well, then you can create a sort of kit,
a grab bag of things that
you can use in any context
or I should say that you can look to
depending on the context you're in
and create the states of
body and mind that you want.
Now once again, painting
with a somewhat broad brush,
but nonetheless, an accurate brush,
we can say that dopamine,
when elevated above baseline,
tends to increase states of motivation,
both mental and physical motivation,
drive and to some extent focus.
I've said it many times
before, and I'll say it again,
there's a lot of
misconception about dopamine.
Many people out there think that dopamine
is all about pleasure.
You hear about dopamine hits
or people chasing dopamine
or the need to have a
dopamine fast, et cetera.
Dopamine is not about pleasure.
Dopamine is about motivation,
craving and pursuit
for goals or for things that are outside
our immediate possession and experience.
The motivation and pursuit of a mate.
The motivation and pursuit to mate.
The motivation and pursuit of food.
The motivation and
pursuit of a career goal,
et cetera, et cetera,
things we do not yet
have, but that we want
and we get into sort of
a forward center of mass
and a pursuit of, and that
pursuit can be physical.
That pursuit can be cognitive.
It can be both cognitive and physical.
And it can involve talking
about something, right?
Because in some professions,
pursuit of things involves talking.
I think about lawyers,
they talk a lot in
pursuit of winning cases
and money, et cetera,
putting people in jail or
keeping people out of jail,
et cetera, that's done with their mouths,
not with their bodies.
Athletes in a state of motivated training
or in motivated competition
use their bodies.
All this is obvious of course,
but perhaps what is not so obvious
is that one molecule not working alone,
but predominantly one molecule, dopamine,
is responsible for all of
those motivated states,
which again, underscores the
power of these neuromodulators.
So dopamine, we can think of
at least in the context
of today's discussion
as controlling and indeed
promoting motivation,
drive and pursuit
and to some extent, focus.
Epinephrine and a closely related molecule
called norepinephrine
and again, I want to emphasize
that epinephrine is adrenaline
and adrenaline is epinephrine.
Norepinephrine is noradrenaline
and noradrenaline is norepinephrine,
but today we're going to
just simply talk about
epinephrine and norepinephrine.
That category of neuromodulator
is mainly responsible for
generating our energy,
our level of fuel
and baseline level of
forward center of mass,
as I like to call it.
You can also think of it
as how high your RPM are.
Now we're not a car
and the car analogy sort of falls apart
as we go further into the biology,
but it's a decent one for now.
When epinephrine levels are high,
we tend to feel agitated,
we tend to feel like we want to move,
we tend to feel like we
can't shut down our thinking
and our anticipation of
what's going to happen next.
And when epinephrine
levels are very, very low,
we actually have less physical energy.
We tend to have less mental energy
in terms of generating
thoughts very quickly
and so on and so forth.
And as I mentioned before,
dopamine and epinephrine
are closely related
so much so that we know for a fact
that epinephrine is actually manufactured
from the molecule dopamine.
So that's why I'm talking
about these two neuromodulators
in very close juxtaposition
because they do indeed
collaborate with one another.
But for sake of today's discussion,
we can just think of epinephrine
as increasing energy,
adrenaline increases energy
in our state of readiness.
It also, I should mention,
activates our immune system.
Contrary to popular belief
that stress inhibits our immune system,
epinephrine is deployed,
it's released at great
levels in our brain and body
when we are stressed.
And that actually protects us
against infections of multiple kinds,
at least in the short-term.
That and all the details of that
and tools related to that
were covered in our episode
on the immune system,
if you want to check that out.
Now the neuromodulator serotonin
creates a number of different
states in the brain and body,
but for sake of today's discussion,
we're going to think about
the predominant states
that it creates
and those are states of contentness,
being happy, feeling fairly relaxed,
feeling soothed and to some extent,
even some relief from
pain or lack of pain.
Serotonin is associated
with a feeling of satiety
of having enough of what we already have.
Now when serotonin is very, very high,
people can even be sedate.
They can be completely amotivated,
no motivation to seek out things
like food or sex or work or et cetera.
Whereas when serotonin
levels are very low,
people can actually exhibit agitation
and high levels of stress.
So the levels matter here,
but again, for sake of
today's conversation,
when we leverage serotonin,
we are really leveraging a neuromodulator
that tends to increase the activity
of neural circuits in the brain and body
that make us feel relaxed and happy.
And it tends to decrease the
activity of neural circuits
that make us rabidly in pursuit of things
that we don't have, right.
The opposite of content and sated
is motivation, desire
and hunger and thirst
for things that we don't have.
So serotonin is the molecule of peace.
It is the molecule of contentness.
It is the molecule of having enough,
at least for the time being
or the feeling that we have
enough for the time being.
Now acetylcholine is a fourth
category of neuromodulator
that as I mentioned earlier,
is somewhat not totally,
but somewhat distinct
from any direct control
by the major hormone systems of the body,
or at least the major
steroid hormone systems.
And acetylcholine we can say
is mainly associated with states of focus.
And we can go a step further and say
that it's mainly associated
with steps of focus
as they relate to learning
and encoding new information,
so called neuroplasticity.
Now neuroplasticity,
or the brain and nervous
system's ability to change
in response to experience
can be impacted by an enormous number
of different chemicals,
not just acetylcholine,
but acetylcholine has a
particularly potent ability
to open up the thing that
we call neuroplasticity
to allow plasticity to
happen in one moment
whereas in a previous moment,
it could not occur
because acetylcholine had not
been released in the brain
or in the spinal cord.
So acetylcholine is involved
in focus and in learning,
but it is not necessarily
always associated
with learning in the
context of highly motivated,
really ramped up states.
It can be,
but acetylcholine can also be released
and can encourage the learning
and neuroplasticity
associated with calm states.
For instance, if somebody
has a newborn child,
we know that they are
flooded with oxytocin,
which has actually even
been called the love hormone
or it does many things in
addition to control feelings
of romantic attachment
and attachment to children, et cetera.
It does all of that, but it
does a lot more, as well.
But when people have a new child,
they also tend to be
hyper-focused on that child,
not just its well-being,
but they narrow all their thinking,
all their vision,
all their hearing to that child
and there are obvious adaptive reasons
for wanting to do that.
I recall a family dinner we had.
Gosh, this was over 10 years ago.
We had a couple over.
My mom was in the habit
of inviting people over
who didn't have places
to go on the holidays,
'cause that's just who she is
and I think it's quite nice.
So she brought over this
couple, they had a newborn,
I think this baby had been born
maybe two or three weeks before
and it was seated or not seated [laughs].
It was lying down.
I couldn't see it.
It was like a potato bug.
It could barely hold its head up.
But it was lying in a
little bassinet on the floor
as we ate dinner.
And it was almost hilarious,
it actually was hilarious.
We laughed a lot about this,
that the entire meal,
they were basically staring at this baby.
They were so clearly in love with the baby
and so flooded with
oxytocin and also prolactin
that they couldn't take
their focus off this baby.
It was actually really
wonderful and endearing to see.
But in addition to that,
I'd be willing to bet
had I been able to do a
little bit of microdialysis,
which is a ability to
measure the amounts of neuromodulator
given location in the brain,
had I been able to do
that experiment on them
in that moment, I
would've found that levels
of acetylcholine were exceedingly high
because they were so
hyper-focused on this child,
not just in love with,
but focused on that child.
And without a doubt,
the neural circuits related to focus
and plasticity were heavily engaged
again for obvious adaptive
reasons related to child rearing
and learning the coos and cries
and pain signals and pleasure
signals of one's offspring.
So we have dopamine
associated with motivation,
drive and pursuit and
to some extent, focus.
We have epinephrine and
norepinephrine associated
with energy of having a
forward center of mass,
mentally and or physically.
We have serotonin,
which is associated with a peaceful,
content, sated state of being.
And we have acetylcholine,
which is associated with focus
and in particular focus
as it relates to learning
and encoding new information.
So let's say you want
to be more motivated.
You want to be more in pursuit of goals.
And you want to have more
energy and to be more focused.
There are many ways to go about that.
In fact, there's a near
infinite cloud of opportunities,
everything from prescription
drugs to illicit drugs,
which I certainly do not recommend,
supplements, nutrition.
You can listen to particular music.
You can do all sorts of
cognitive behavioral,
nutritional supplementation tricks.
Or you can just understand
that what you're really after
are increases in dopamine
above baseline that you control
and there are ways to control
them that are quite potent
and science tells us which tools
are going to be the most potent
and the most versatile for you.
So I'm going to share
those tools with you now
with the caveat that
each one of those tools
could be its own entire podcast episode,
and that we've done near entire episodes
on each of these tools or small
collections of these tools.
So I'm going to cover these in
somewhat superficial manner.
We can provide links to previous episodes
that relate to each of
these tools in detail,
but I'll give you enough detail about them
that would allow you to
incorporate them into your routine
should you choose.
Let's say you want to increase dopamine
for sake of increasing motivation.
The first thing to do is
to understand what the
natural behavioral tools are
for increasing dopamine
and to do those as
consistently as possible.
Again, these are tools
that you'll want to do
nearly every day, if not every day.
And I know I'm sounding like
a broken record on this one,
but here again, we come to sunlight
and I should say,
not just the desire to,
but really the need
for viewing the maximum amount of sunlight
that one can reasonably get
given schedules and
locations in the world,
time of year, et cetera,
in the early part of the day,
within the first hour of waking, ideally,
but certainly in the first
three hours of your day,
you are going to want to
maximize sunlight exposure
to your eyes.
Never look at the sun or
any other light so bright
that it's painful to look at.
And yes, of course blinking is fine,
but no, take sunglasses off,
go outside once the sun is out
and get some natural light in your eyes.
And if it's appropriate
or I should say in a
way that's appropriate,
maximize the amount of
sunlight exposure to your skin,
but please don't get burned.
Please do wear sunscreen if
you're prone to getting burned.
Typically early day sunlight
is not going to burn you,
at least not most people,
unless you're extremely fair-skinned.
So don't get burned.
Do what you need to in order
to protect yourself from burn.
There's some emerging
controversy about sunscreen
and which ones are safe
and which ones aren't safe.
We have not done an episode on that yet,
but I find it to be an
important and interesting topic.
Darya Rose, Dr. Darya Rose, I should say,
has a podcast called
The Darya Rose Podcast
and did an episode all about sunscreens,
which are safe, which are not safe,
by interviewing an expert on that
so I refer you to that podcast
as it relates to sunscreen.
But get some natural light
exposure in your eyes.
And if you wake up
before the sun comes out,
turn on as many bright lights inside
as you can turn on reasonably
given your electric bill, et cetera.
Get a lot of bright sunlight
exposure early in the day
and get a lot of sunlight
exposure to your skin
in the early part of the day,
in a way that doesn't burn you,
meaning burn your skin
or blind you, please.
Please don't do anything
that harms your vision
like stare into a bright
light, that's painful.
What does that do?
Well, it sets in motion a number
of different biological cascades.
Some are very fast.
There are fast actions of sunlight
that will trigger for instance,
dopamine release from
different parts of your brain
and your endocrine system.
And we now know that it
increases levels of genes
related to thyroid hormone
and actually increases
certain dopamine receptors.
So there's a wonderful paper.
We will provide a link to this paper
that shows that sunlight exposure
can actually increase the
amount of so-called DRD4.
This is a particular type
of dopamine receptor,
the dopamine receptor four.
The genes for dopamine receptor four
are actually under photic control.
So if you get sunlight
exposure to your eyes
and it does have to be to your eyes
in the early part of the day,
you increase the amount of
dopamine receptor that you have,
which allows whatever circulating dopamine
happens to be there
to have a greater effect on motivation
and I should say also on mood and feelings
of being in pursuit and generally,
in craving and pursuit of things in life.
Now there's another way
to increase the effect
of whatever dopamine
happens to be circulating
in your brain and body.
And this again, relates
to increasing the number
or the efficacy of the
receptors for dopamine.
Now here we're not talking about
the dopamine receptor four,
but a different category
of dopamine receptors,
the D2 and D3 receptors,
which are expressed multiple
places in your brain and body
and bind dopamine,
meaning dopamine parks in
them like a parking spot
and allows dopamine
to generally increase the
activity of the neurons
and cells that express
those dopamine receptors.
How do you do that?
Well, turns out that regular
ingestion of caffeine
at safe and appropriate levels,
about a hundred to 250 milligrams
is going to increase the number of D2
and D3 dopamine receptors.
I talked a little bit about
this on a previous episode.
Again, we'll provide
links to these studies,
but this is an important finding,
I believe, because this
is not about the acute,
the immediate effects of
caffeine on alertness,
although those occur, too.
When you drink caffeine,
it's going to increase
your levels of adrenaline
and so-called epinephrine,
which will increase your energy levels.
It's going to decrease levels
of something called adenosine,
which builds up while you're sleepy.
It's going to make you feel
less sleepy, more alert,
more energetic.
That's sort of obvious.
But what's less obvious is
that it's increasing the number
and efficacy of dopamine receptors
so that whatever dopamine
happens to be around
in your system is going to
have more of a potent effect.
So how much caffeine should you drink?
That's going to vary
from person to person.
Some people are very sensitive
to caffeine, others are not.
I tend to be fairly
insensitive to caffeine,
'cause I've been drinking it
for a long period of time.
But you know, after one or two
cups of espresso or coffee,
I feel like I've had enough.
I tend to drink my
caffeine early in the day,
which is what I'm going
to recommend that you do,
not drinking caffeine past
two and certainly not 4:00 PM,
if you're on a typical schedule
and you want to be able
to sleep that night,
even if you can fall asleep.
Having too much caffeine
in your system is not good
because it disrupts the
architecture of sleep.
And now knowing about all
the metabolic variability
across the night, according
to different stages of sleep,
it should be even more obvious
as to why disrupting the
architecture of sleep
would be bad for you.
So limit that caffeine
intake to early in the day
and don't go ballistic.
Certainly don't go ballistic in any case,
but for most people anywhere
from 100 to 400 milligrams of caffeine
is going to have this effect.
And this effect again is
a slow accumulating effect
by drinking caffeine
consistently day-to-day.
I get my caffeine mainly
from Yerba Mate tea.
I want to emphasize that
it's probably a good idea
to stay away from the smoked mates.
There's some evidence
those can be carcinogenic,
but I brew my own Yerba Mate tea,
or sometimes I'll drink
coffee or espresso,
or sometimes both frankly,
as long as I'm hydrating enough
and I'm getting enough salt,
then I tend to feel fine
with that much caffeine.
The other way to increase dopamine
and to make sure that your
baseline levels of dopamine
are high enough is to make sure
that you're eating sufficient numbers
of tyrosine-rich foods.
You can look up which
foods include tyrosine.
Tyrosine is a precursor to dopamine.
It's an amino acid that
is in direct pathway
to dopamine synthesis
and tyrosine foods include things like
certain meats, Parmesan cheese,
very high in tyrosine, for instance.
In fact, there's something
called the cheese effect,
believe it or not.
I don't want to go too far off topic,
but the cheese effect
is kind of interesting
because certain people
will take antidepressants
that are so called MAO inhibitors,
monoamine oxidase inhibitors.
Anytime you hear ASE, that's an enzyme.
They will take these inhibitors
that prevent the breakdown of dopamine
and other so-called catacholamines,
which allow more dopamine
to be in circulation.
But if these people eat certain cheeses,
including Parmesan cheese,
and there are other foods,
of course that include not just tyrosine,
but one of the derivatives of tyrosine,
called tyramine,
that generates what's
called the cheese effect,
which is people get potent migraines,
headaches, blood pressure goes up.
Why, well, because they've
got a lot of tyrosine
in their system and
dopamine in their system.
And they've got less of the enzyme
that removes that dopamine
or limits its action
and so they have an excess of dopamine
and dopamine has effects on
blood pressure, et cetera.
So the cheese effect is something to avoid
if you are somebody who's taking drugs
that tap into or manipulate
the dopamine pathway,
either for Parkinson's or depressions,
obviously you're going
to want to be careful
about adjusting up or down
levels of dopamine too potently.
So mind the cheese effect
if you're taking an MAO inhibitor.
There's a lot of information
about this online.
For most people, eating
foods like Parmesan cheese,
eating foods like certain
meats and certain vegetables
also can increase tyrosine levels,
which will increase dopamine synthesis.
So these are ways of
modulating, more or less,
the baseline of dopamine
that you are able to produce
and the ways that dopamine
can have its action
by way of binding to
receptors more potently.
Now there are other ways
to increase dopamine
in a more acute or directed way,
ways to spike your dopamine,
to enhance your state of
motivation, mood, focus and so on.
And in thinking about the
vast landscape of tools
that can do that,
we have one category of tools,
which are the really, really bad things
that I don't recommend anybody do.
In fact, I recommend nobody do ever,
which are things like cocaine,
methamphetamine, et cetera.
They are incredibly destructive for lives
because of the way that they
so potently increase dopamine
and then the crash in
dopamine that occurs later.
I mean, they can indeed
and often do ruin lives.
So we're leaving those off the table.
There are of course, prescription
drugs that many people,
especially people who have
clinically diagnosed ADHD,
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder,
rely on and in fact
benefit from in many cases,
things like Ritalin, Adderall, Vyvanse.
Nowadays, there's also
a lot of interest in use
of things like Modafinil, Armodafinil.
I covered all of those
in the episode on ADHD.
And you can find that on HubermanLab.com
and the other places
this podcast is found.
Prescription drugs aside because
they require a prescription
and a discussion that's in-depth
and appropriate with your
physician, healthcare provider.
There are supplements
that can very potently
increase dopamine as well,
perhaps not to the extent
that some of those other
prescription drugs can,
but certainly to a degree that will impact
and increase dopamine and motivation
and the other states
dopamine is associated with.
And the two main categories of supplements
that are very effective
in raising dopamine
and here I should provide the caveat
that anytime you're going
to add or remove anything
from your supplementation protocols,
please talk to a physician
who is knowledgeable on these topics.
If you're somebody who has,
or is taking drugs for
depression or mania,
please be very cautious about
manipulating your dopamine
in any case.
I don't just say that to protect us,
I say that to protect you.
But if we were to look at
the supplement landscape
and ask which supplement
increased dopamine,
there are a vast number of them,
but the three main ones,
the most effective ones that
are readily available out there
without a prescription
are mucuna pruriens.
This is actually the
outside of a velvety bean
that has been extracted
and put into a supplement.
Mucuna pruriens is actual L-dopa.
It's 99% L-dopa, which
is a prescription drug
that is given for Parkinson's
and for other purposes
where increasing dopamine is important.
I don't recommend mucuna pruriens.
I'm not saying that no one should take it,
but I don't take it.
And I don't recommend it
because it tends to so potently
and acutely increase dopamine,
that there's a pretty
substantial crash afterwards.
So I avoid it and I
don't generally suggest
that anyone take it unless
there's really a clinical need,
or they're working very
closely with somebody
that can really monitor that.
The other two supplements
that can increase dopamine
in a short-term way,
but in a significant way,
are L-tyrosine
so you can buy that as
a supplement amino acid.
I sometimes take this.
I would say, I probably take
it about once a week maximum
for work bouts or workouts.
I'll take it in dosages of anywhere
from 500 milligrams to
a thousand milligrams.
People vary tremendously
in their sensitivity
to supplementing L-tyrosine.
I know people that can take two grams.
I know people that can barely
take a hundred milligrams.
I know people that the best dose for them
is zero milligrams.
So there's a lot of variation
there depending on sensitivity
and they're natural
baseline levels of dopamine
and whether or not they're
doing a lot of other things
to support dopamine,
but nonetheless, taking
L-tyrosine will lead
to fairly substantial
increases in dopamine
within about 15 to 45 minutes
and it lasts for about
30 minutes to two hours
and then there's kind of a tapering off.
Some people experience a
little bit of an emotional
and or I should say energetic
crash, some people don't.
And then the other supplement
that I certainly use,
and that I know a number
of other people use
is more fast-acting, but more potent,
which is phenylethylamine.
This relates to the
so-called PEA molecule,
PEA, P-E-A,
and phenylethylamine increases dopamine
and some metabolites related to dopamine
in ways that really increase energy
and feelings of well-being and motivation.
And again, it's fast-acting.
So my particular protocol,
the one I use is I'll
take phenylethylamine
at dosages of about 300 to 600 milligrams
along with some L-tyrosine,
or I'll take it on its
own with a molecule,
or I should say a compound
that we'll talk about a little bit later
as it relates to acetylcholine, Alpha-GPC,
but tyrosine and phenylethylamine
taken alone or together
will make you feel more
motivated and more alert,
more willing and able to lean into
particular motivated behaviors,
whether or not they're
physical or cognitive.
If you'd like to learn
more about these compounds
and their supplementation
and their effects,
I encourage you to check out
the ever valuable website, examine.com.
It's zero cost to access,
and they provide references
and some more details
about these sorts of compounds
and other related compounds.
Now if we are going to
look at behavioral tools
for potently increasing dopamine,
that too is a vast landscape.
And we know based on hundreds,
if not thousands of studies
that things like winning
at some sort of competition
or succeeding in reaching a goal
can certainly increase dopamine.
We talk a lot about this in the episode
on dopamine, motivation and drive,
but leaving that aside,
there are certain behavioral protocols
that are unrelated to your
overall goals and motivations
that can increase dopamine
in a very sustained way.
And without question,
the most potent behavioral
tool for doing that
is going to be deliberate, cold exposure.
Deliberate cold exposure has
been talked about a lot here
and elsewhere in terms of its
ability to do things
like reduce inflammation
as a way to test and improve resilience
because uncomfortable cold,
provided its applied safely
is a great way to learn
to be more resilient
because you're essentially
staying or forcing yourself
to stay in a circumstance
where your system is
flooded with adrenaline.
But one lesser known aspect
of deliberate cold exposure
is one that's been demonstrated
quite convincingly in humans,
comes from a study
published in the year 2000.
I'll link to this study.
I love this study by the way.
Covered it many times on this podcast
because I love it so much and
I think it's truly important.
And that's the study from Srámek et al,
entitled, "Human physiological responses
"to immersion into water
of different temperatures".
I'm not going to go into
this into a ton of detail
for sake of time,
but basically what they show is that
putting people into cold water,
and I should mention
the water that they used
in this study wasn't that cold.
They had a bunch of different conditions,
but they had people that
got into, for instance,
60 degree Fahrenheit
water for up to two hours,
had them sitting there,
had them in a lawn chair up to their neck,
had very long sustained increases
in dopamine transmission
and dopamine circulation
in their brain and body.
And also some of the other catacholamines,
as I mentioned before,
dopamine tends to
collaborate with epinephrine
and vice versa.
Now you don't need to put yourself
into 60 degree Fahrenheit water
to get these kind of sustained increases.
And you certainly don't
need to do it for two hours.
We have a strong reason to believe
based on subsequent studies,
in fact, published just this last year,
that getting into much colder water
of say 50 degrees or 55 degrees
or even 45 degrees Fahrenheit
can potently increase dopamine
and epinephrine, as well.
And that you don't need to expose yourself
to that cold water for nearly as long.
So perhaps even as short as
one minute or even 30 seconds
exposure to really cold water,
can lead to these potent
long-lasting increases in dopamine.
Many people will ask
which protocols to follow.
For instance, will a cold shower suffice?
Very likely, yes, if your
shower gets cold enough.
Do you need ice floating in the bath?
No, it's all about the temperature
not whether or not there's
ice present or not.
How long to stay in there?
There are a lot of details
that we don't have time
to go into this episode.
Please see the episode on
the Use of Deliberate Cold
for Health and Performance.
You'll find that at HubermanLab.com.
We have a newsletter related to this.
It gets into a lot of detailed protocols,
but in general, we can say
that the way to evoke dopamine
and epinephrine release
using cold water is to
ideally you would do cold water immersion.
If you can't, you'd use cold shower,
but you want to use a
temperature that is safe,
meaning you're not going
to have a heart attack,
but that is uncomfortable
such that you really want to get out
and then staying in for
anywhere from one minute
to 10 minutes, depending on
how cold adapted you are,
and then getting out
and drying off and going about your day,
unless you have some other protocol
that you're trying to
extract from the cold.
So this is a cold exposure protocol
specifically aimed at increasing dopamine.
For some people out there, you might think
this is kind of silly using
cold water to increase dopamine.
But when you look at the data in humans
on the effect of cold water exposure
to stimulate long-lasting,
very significant increases
in dopamine and epinephrine,
I think you'll agree that
this is a really potent tool
that provided its given
safely and gone about safely,
is giving you the kinds
of increases in dopamine
that you would seek using
prescription pharmacology.
Now it shouldn't be used as a replacement
for prescription pharmacology,
although people have done that to success.
One of the previous guest
on the Huberman Lab Podcast
was Dr. Anna Lembke, our director
of the Dual Diagnosis
Addiction Clinic at Stanford.
She has an amazing book
called "Dopamine Nation",
all about dopamine and
both its uses, healthy,
and its perils in things like addiction.
And she describes a patient of hers
that used deliberate cold exposure
to try and maintain dopamine levels
while coming off of drugs
that were increasing dopamine so potently
that they were putting him
down the path of addiction.
So the use of cold water
for increasing dopamine
is a real tool.
It's, I would say, a power tool.
In fact, it's the kind
of thing that if you want
to increase dopamine
for sake of motivation,
it might be your first go-to
provided you're also doing the things
to maintain dopamine baseline
like sunlight exposure in particular,
making sure you're
getting sufficient amounts
of tyrosine-containing foods and so on.
And now just very briefly,
I want to point to a few quick tools
that good peer review data tell us
can be leveraged in order to make sure
that you have sufficient
dopamine when you want it
or that it's available
for it to be released
by any number of the
tools I provided thus far.
And those are sufficient
number of B vitamins.
So it turns out that B vitamins,
in particular B6 or vitamin B6,
can potently reduce prolactin levels.
And again, prolactin and
dopamine tend to work
in kind of push pull fashion.
That said you should be cautious
about taking excessive levels of B6.
It is a vitamin that if you take too much,
you'll likely excrete
it through your urine,
but there is evidence that having
excessively high levels of B6
or supplementing with
can cause some peripheral neuropathy,
some death of nerves in the periphery.
If you want to know what dosage
levels are relevant there
just simply look it up online.
There's a lot of information about this.
But you do want to make sure
that you're getting
enough B6, B12, et cetera,
such that you can keep
prolactin levels in check.
And if you suspect that you
have a dopamine deficiency,
please talk to your doctor
and talk to them about
ways you might adjust
that prolactin down and
thereby dopamine up.
The other way to ensure that
dopamine levels stay high
or put differently,
that you don't quash whatever dopamine
you have in your system
is to really avoid bright
light exposure to your eyes
between the hours of 10:00 PM and 4:00 AM
or another way of putting this
because I realize people sleep
at different times, et cetera,
is to avoid bright light
exposure to your eyes,
not just blue light,
but all colors of light
in phase three, that is 17
to 24 hours after waking up
because that's really
when you should be asleep
or trying to get asleep, if
you're having trouble sleeping.
Work from Samer Hattar's lab,
the director of the chronobiology unit
at the National Institutes
of Mental Health,
again, a previous Huberman
Lab Podcast guest,
tell us that bright light exposure
in phase three of your circadian cycle,
17 to 24 hours after waking,
can have dramatic effects
in reducing dopamine levels
by way of activating a neural circuit
involving something called the habenula.
I don't want to get into
too many details right now,
but really try and keep the lights dim
in the middle of the night or off,
if you can do that safely.
It's really going to help
if you're turning on your phone brightly,
if you are turning on bright lights,
it's not just going to
negatively impact melatonin,
the hormone that helps
you fall and stay asleep.
It's also going to negatively
impact dopamine levels,
not just that night,
but the subsequent day.
So that more or less
summarizes our coverage
of ways to use behavior and
supplementation and nutrition
to increase dopamine
and dopamine receptor efficacy and number,
and to keep sufficient amounts of dopamine
in your system day-to-day for
motivation, mood and focus.
And of course, keep in mind those things
that can suppress dopamine,
the bright light exposure,
elevated prolactin, and so on.
My hope is that by
understanding those tools
and how they work
and understanding that
dopamine does certain things
and not others
that you can assemble a
versatile kit of behaviors
and other things that you can do
in order to adjust your dopamine levels
according to your particular goals.
I want to just briefly
return to the fact, however,
that all of that is
riding on that phase one,
phase two background,
meaning, it's probably going to
take less cold water exposure,
or I should say less time
doing cold water exposure
early in the day
to get a big increase in dopamine
than it would later in the day.
Because later in the day, your
baseline levels of dopamine
are lower and you've got
more serotonin circulating.
That should make sense to you
now as to why that's the case.
And does that mean
that you should really modify
your protocols dramatically?
Probably not, but you
might keep that in mind
that if, for instance, you need
to be in a highly motivated,
focused state in the late part of the day,
for whatever reason,
it might take a few or more of these tools
in combination in order
to accomplish that.
Whereas if you're somebody
who feels pretty good
during the day, but you're
kind of lacking motivation
and you want to increase dopamine levels
and you don't yet need to,
or want to resort to prescription
drugs or supplementation,
well, then you might layer in
a couple behavioral protocols
paying attention to of course,
the things that you might be doing
that would also potentially
suppress dopamine.
So again, that kit of tools is designed
for you to play with, if you choose,
if it's safe for you to
apply them, then do that.
Consider doing them individually,
not trying to hit all the
tools all at once, right?
I mean, why throw all those tools
at your dopamine system at once?
Better would be to have
those tools in your kit
and be able to deploy them depending on
whether or not you're on travel,
whether or not you're
eating well or less well,
sleeping well or less well.
That's highly individual
and I'd like to think that in
having those tools in hand,
you'll be able to adjust them
and apply them in the ways
that allow you to access
the dopamine increases
that you're after.
So next I'd like to
talk about epinephrine,
also called adrenaline.
I want to point out that epinephrine
is released both in
the brain and the body.
In fact, there's a barrier
between brain and body
that prevents the
epinephrine that's released
from your adrenal glands,
from crossing the blood brain barrier.
So your brain has a separate site
called the locus coeruleus.
This is a collection of neurons
in the back of the brain
that kind of sprinkler
the rest of the brain
with epinephrine
and essentially wakes up
whatever neural circuits
happen to see, or I should say,
wake up any circuits
where that epinephrine
happens to arrive, right,
and generally increase the
excitability of those networks.
That's why we say
epinephrine increases energy.
I'm not talking about caloric energy,
although that's distantly related to this,
but really energy and the desire to move,
the feeling that we can think,
the feeling that we can be alert.
In fact, if you look at somebody
and their eyelids are wide open,
in large part,
that's because of a lot of
adrenaline in their system.
If their pupils are really big
and their eyes are really wide open,
in general, that means they have
a lot of epinephrine circulating there,
whereas when we're tired
and we're kind of hood-eyed
and we're sort of sleepy,
or our pupils are really small,
in general, that's because
levels of epinephrine
and also dopamine, remember
they work together,
levels of epinephrine and
dopamine tend to be lower.
This is also why when
people take any drug,
like again, not recommending this,
amphetamine or cocaine or any stimulant,
their pupils tend to be huge.
Their eyes tend to be wide open.
They don't blink very often.
And the opposite is true
when people take sedatives.
So it all starts to make sense
when you think about the
basic actions of these things.
For many people, increasing
adrenaline or epinephrine
might seem like a crazy idea.
Most people probably associate
this molecule with stress
and then would like to be less stressed.
And we've done entire
episodes about stress,
how to master stress,
how to leverage stress,
how to conquer stress.
There are a lot of great tools to do that
that are behavioral,
supplementation-based.
Please see the episode on
Mastering Stress for those tools,
but there are people, including me,
that want to increase
our levels of epinephrine
at least early in the day.
I'm somebody who wakes up rather slowly.
In fact, right after waking up,
I rarely want to bounce out of bed.
I try and push myself to do that.
I'm always impressed by
these chakra-willy types
that are up at 4:30 or up at
five and already into action.
I tend to be kind of thinking about
thinking about maybe being
in action early in the day,
but I try and push myself
to get into action,
which itself can increase epinephrine.
I should mention that
any physical activity,
walking, running, weight
lifting, swimming,
even talking for that matter
is going to increase
levels of epinephrine.
Locus coeruleus is a brain structure
that is tightly coupled with behaviors
in a bidirectional way.
That is, when you are in action,
you increase the amount
of epinephrine released
from locus coeruleus.
You wake up the brain.
And conversely, when
locus coeruleus is active,
the brain wakes up, so it's reciprocal.
It goes both directions.
So I saw a funny tweet
actually earlier today,
it was something like
going to the gym gives you energy,
but you need energy to go to the gym.
Sounds like a pyramid scheme to me,
which made me chuckle.
But of course overlooks the fact that,
indeed, if you have energy,
you are more likely to be willing
to get into physical movement
or cognitive movement and thinking hard
or thinking a lot about something.
But also it is absolutely
scientifically proven
that being in action
increases levels of epinephrine.
This is why exercising early in the day
gives you more energy for rest of day.
You still might experience
a little bit of a crash
in the afternoon,
especially if you're
getting up extra early,
or if you're drinking
caffeine too close to waking.
I've talked about this before.
If you drink too much
caffeine close to waking,
you're going to have an afternoon crash.
Better to push that caffeine intake out
about 90 to 120 minutes after waking.
I know this is really
painful for certain people,
but caffeine does increase epinephrine.
Caffeine does other things
to limit sleepiness.
And by pushing it out 90 to
120 minutes after waking,
you will avoid the afternoon
crash to a large degree.
And if you get up and you exercise
or even do any movement of any kind,
a hundred jumping jacks or a
walk, if you can't do that,
anything like that will increase
the total amount of
epinephrine that you secrete
into your bloodstream and in your brain
and will get you more energy,
not just in that moment,
but throughout the day.
So keep that in mind.
Exercise does indeed give you energy.
It burns caloric energy,
but it gives you neural energy
by way of increasing
epinephrine transmission
from locus coeruleus.
And presumably if the
exercise is intense enough,
adrenaline, epinephrine release,
from the adrenals within
your body, as well.
So we have exercise and we have caffeine
as potent tools for increasing epinephrine
and thereby, energy.
Another potent tool
that's purely behavioral,
but is known to work,
based on excellent studies in humans.
And actually my laboratory has been doing
similar types of studies
that are soon to be published, we hope,
is so-called cyclic hyperventilation.
Some of you may be familiar
with Wim Hof breathing.
There's also Tummo breathing,
which is very similar,
Kundalini breathing.
All of those styles of breathing
involve cyclic hyperventilation,
deep inhales, and either passive
exhales or active exhales,
but repeating, inhale,
exhale, inhale, exhale,
in a very deep and repetitive way.
If you were to do that right now,
doesn't matter if you do it
through your nose or mouth,
although ideally you would do
the inhale through your nose
and the exhale through your mouth,
if you did that for 25 repetitions,
25 inhales and exhales,
you would feel more alert.
You'd also feel more warm, why?
Because you increased
epinephrine, adrenaline release
in the brain and body.
It works the first time
and it works every time
to increase epinephrine
and thereby energy.
And in fact, there are protocols
and great scientific studies
of using cyclic hyperventilation
for periods of minutes, if not longer,
where for instance, you would
do 25 big inhales and exhales
followed by a brief breath
hold with your lungs empty,
then repeat 25, then brief breath hold,
excuse me, exhale, hold your lungs empty.
And then repeat again for
a third round, if you like.
If you do that over and over,
you're going to be very alert.
You're going to have more energy.
You're going to feel like
you want to move around a lot more.
In fact, you might even feel agitated.
So people with a lot of anxiety
or prone to panic attack
might want to be cautious
in how they train and embark
on that type of breathing,
might want to approach it
a little more carefully
or avoid it altogether.
But for most people,
cyclic hyperventilation is simply going to
get you more energized and
feeling like you want to move,
feeling like you can think more clearly,
and you'll be more wide-eyed and alert
because you are releasing adrenaline.
And the cold water exposure protocol
that I talked about earlier
and that's covered in our episode on cold
and in the newsletter on cold.
Well that, as I mentioned earlier,
potently increases dopamine,
but also epinephrine.
So that's another terrific tool,
whether or not it's applied by
cold shower or cold immersion
or some other thing like cryo,
that is going to make you more alert
because it releases adrenaline.
Now we can't really say
that there are foods
to increase epinephrine.
Rather, there are foods that
include a lot of tyrosine
that will increase dopamine.
And remember, dopamine is the molecule
from which epinephrine is synthesized.
So we can't really point
to a particular food
or categories of food for
increasing epinephrine.
I think caffeine and things like it
will increase epinephrine.
There are of course prescription drugs
that will increase epinephrine.
And of course,
there are all sorts of
so-called beta blockers
that will block the
receptors for epinephrine
to make you feel calm for public speaking
or for various heart
conditions, et cetera.
That's really the domain of physicians
and should really be worked
out with your cardiologist,
with a physician et cetera.
I think the tools of exercise
and should you want very
potent increases in adrenaline,
high intensity exercise,
as well as the tools of
caffeine, cyclic hyperventilation
and deliberate cold exposure,
really combine to give
you a nice little kit,
I would say a versatile kit,
of ways to increase epinephrine
for sake of having more
physical and mental energy.
So next is the
neuromodulator acetylcholine.
And as I mentioned earlier,
acetylcholine is associated
with states of focus
and those states of focus
can be high energy states of focus.
So the ones that are accompanied by
high levels of dopamine and epinephrine
and where we're really excited about
and really lasered in on something,
or they can be the calmer,
more relaxed states of focus
like reading a book or practicing music
or listening very carefully to somebody
in a way that's relaxed and calm.
And yet nonetheless,
where we have a narrow cognitive
and typically a narrow visual aperture,
and typically also a
narrow auditory aperture.
That is our auditory system
and our visual system
and our thinking can be very broad.
It can be all over the place.
Or it can be very narrow.
And it can be very focused.
Acetylcholine is released from
two major sites in the brain,
nucleus basalis, which is in the forebrain
and extends connections out
to many different brain areas
to offer the opportunity to
release acetylcholine locally
and more or less in a chemical way,
highlight those particular
neurons and synapses
for strengthening, for plasticity later.
And it is released from sites
in the back of the brain
in a way that can increase
the so-called fidelity
of information coming in
through our eyes, our
ears, our nose, et cetera.
What do I mean by fidelity?
Well, we are constantly being bombarded
with sensory information through
all of our various senses
and acetylcholine released from this area
in the back of the brain,
has the ability to increase
the extent to which
say, visual information
or just visual and auditory information
would make it through to our consciousness
whereas all the other types
of sensory information
that are coming in are filtered out.
So your brain, because it's
taking in all this information
needs to decide what to pay attention to.
And in this way, we can
say that acetylcholine
has a lot to do, not just
with "focus", in air quotes,
but literally attention,
which neural signals become
relevant to our consciousness.
There's a whole discussion to be had there
and we don't have time for that.
Rather, I'd like to focus
on what are the tools
that one can use
to maintain healthy
baselines of acetylcholine
and increase acetylcholine
for sake of learning
any type of information,
physical, cognitive, or otherwise.
Now it turns out there
have been a lot of studies,
including many quality
peer reviewed studies
carried out in humans,
looking at what happens
when you increase acetylcholine
levels in the brain
and you accompany that
with the attempt to learn.
And what you find almost always
is that people experience increased focus,
that when measured the neuronal responses
become more specific,
so less broad scale activity in the brain
and more specific neural circuit activity
and that this triggers immediate
and long-lasting changes
in the way those circuits work,
even when acetylcholine
is not being deployed,
so-called neuroplasticity,
the circuits literally change.
So this is great.
The work of Michael Silver at Berkeley,
the work of Mike Merzenich at UCSF,
the work of Michael Kilgard down in Texas,
all of those laboratories
see this again and again, and again.
Increase acetylcholine
before and during learning.
And there's a much higher probability
that the learning will quote, unquote,
"sink in", that the
information will be retained
because those neural circuits change.
Now ways to increase
acetylcholine in a potent way
include again, nutrition
and supplementation.
It is important to have
baseline levels of acetylcholine
be sufficiently high, as well.
And for that really the ideal situation
is to regularly ingest
foods that provide enough
of the precursors for
acetylcholine to be made.
If you go online and
you were to do a search
of which foods contain a lot of choline,
which is related to the
synthesis of acetylcholine,
you would get some
interesting information back.
For instance, beef liver
is the most potent source of choline.
I know nowadays there's kind
of a growing micro trend
if you will, of ingesting beef liver,
even raw liver, which to be honest,
the thought of ingesting
raw liver of any kind
activates my area postrema,
which is the area of the
brain that triggers nausea.
In fact, I'm starting to salivate a bit,
not because I'm hungry,
but I think the whole
concept makes me ill.
Nonetheless, cooked liver
or raw liver for that matter,
or liver of any kind seems
to contain a lot of choline.
I realize most people,
most people are not
going to be running out
and ingesting large amounts of beef liver.
Eggs contain a lot of choline.
Beef contains choline.
Soybeans contain choline.
So there are vegan or non-meat sources,
chicken, fish, mushrooms, kidney beans,
these sorts of things
contain a lot of choline
and there are other vegetables
that contain choline.
So depending on your dietary
preferences and needs,
you can select certain foods to ingest,
to get enough choline to synthesize
enough baseline acetyl choline.
In the realm of supplementation,
there are some excellent tools
for increasing acetylcholine
in the acute short-term,
meaning over the course
of about 30 minutes
out to about two hours
or maybe even four hours.
And the number of different
molecules that can do that,
that are available without a prescription,
at least in the US, is pretty vast.
The most common of those
molecules is actually nicotine.
Nicotinic acetylcholine receptors
are abundant throughout
the body and brain.
They're in various brain circuits.
They are on muscle and yes,
smoking nicotine either
by vaping or cigarette
will activate those nicotinic receptors.
But of course, smoking
is a terrible thing.
It will also activate
things like lung cancer.
So I definitely don't recommend that.
It also activates addiction
because of the ways
that it triggers activation
of the dopamine circuit.
So I think that triggering activation
of acetylcholine-related
pathways by ingesting nicotine
by way of inhalants is
generally a bad idea.
However, some people will chew Nicorette
or other nicotine type gums.
I've never done that,
but I have friends who
actually rely on that.
These are typically former smokers
that are trying not to smoke,
but still want to get some
of the focus enhancement
that they experience from nicotine.
Some people are very
sensitive to nicotine,
and this is important.
Some people are very sensitive
to ingested nicotine.
So nowadays there are
nicotine-dipped toothpicks,
there of course, is nicotine gum
and other sources of nicotine.
Some people can take that and feel fine.
Some people take it and
feel absolutely terrible.
I confess, I've never
actually tried nicotine
in any of those forms so I
don't know how they work for me,
but some people do use them
as cognitive enhancers.
In fact, I know one Nobel
prize winning neuroscientist,
who's quite well known in our field
for chewing Nicorette all day long.
He insists that it really
helps him with his focus
and he is exceedingly
smart and productive,
although I'm sure there
are other reasons for that.
Supplements that I have used and do use
for increasing acetylcholine
are things like Alpha GPC or Huperzinene.
Alpha GPC
is in the choline pathway,
such that more
acetylcholine is synthesized
after you ingest it.
That's the general logic or
framework of how it works.
Whereas Huperzinene is mainly
in the enzymatic pathway.
It tends to adjust how much
acetylcholine is broken down
and lead to net increases
in acetylcholine.
I will often take 300
milligrams of Alpha GPC
prior to workouts or prior
to cognitive work bouts.
But when I say often, I
tend to do this anywhere
from three to four times a
week, typically not every day.
Although there are people
including people who are trying
to offset age-related cognitive decline,
that will take 300 milligrams of Alpha GPC
three times a day, every day,
which closely mimic some of the studies
that have been done on humans,
looking at offsetting
age-related cognitive decline,
using things like Alpha GPC.
I should point out that there
have been a few studies,
a few, not many,
but these studies emphasize that people
who take a lot of Alpha
GPC chronically over time
may be at increased risk for stroke.
I think the data are still out on that
and we need more data.
But for me, in terms of thinking
about the risk benefit profiles,
taking 300 milligrams of Alpha GPC,
most certainly does increase
my ability to focus.
I've noticed that.
I tend to take it alongside caffeine
and phenylethylamine.
So I take that in combination
either before workouts or workbouts,
really sharpens my focus.
And again, I'm doing that three,
maybe four times per week.
And I'm careful to do that
in the early part of the day
so that it does not disrupt my sleep.
Although I have taken Alpha GPC
in the second half of the day,
and I had no trouble sleeping at all.
I don't know what the exact
half life is of the given form
that's typically in supplementation.
It's actually hard to
get that information.
But typically the focus
effects wear off after
about two, maybe four hours maximum.
Now one thing that I don't think
has ever been discussed before,
certainly not on this podcast
is that if you take Alpha GPC,
even semi-regularly,
you may notice that a particular feature
of your blood work will
increase and that's TMAO,
which is sometimes associated
with increased cardiovascular risk.
This may, again, may relate
to some of the potential risk
of very high levels of Alpha
GPC ingestion over many years,
increasing stroke risk.
Again, those studies looked at people
who've been taking it for up to a decade,
but in any case,
one way to prevent the increase in TMAO,
if you're taking Alpha GPC at all
is to take 600 milligrams of garlic
because it contains
something called allicin.
This was a trick that was handed off to me
by Dr. Kyle Gillette,
who again, was a guest on
this podcast some time ago,
talking about hormones and hormone health.
Turns out that ingestion of
600 milligrams of allicin
alongside or even just
same day as Alpha GPC
can really clamp those TMAO levels
that would otherwise increase
if you're taking Alpha GPC.
And indeed I've done the blood work
and that turns out to be the case.
I saw a spike in TMAO.
I started taking 600 milligrams of garlic
and those TMAO levels came down.
And last as it relates to acetylcholine,
but certainly not least,
just as acetylcholine can increase focus,
focus can increase acetylcholine.
I talked a lot about this
in the episode on focus,
but there are behavioral tools
that you can use to enhance focus.
Things like staring at a
particular visual target
at the same distance at
which you're going to perform some work
and doing that for 30 to 60 seconds,
narrowing in a very deliberate
way, your visual field,
and then moving into a focused work about.
That behavioral practice of
narrowing your visual aperture
will increase the amount of
acetylcholine transmission
in particular neural circuits
that will then make it easier to focus.
How do we know that?
Well, I covered in that episode,
some of the peer reviewed studies
that relate to protocols
that are now actively being deployed
in schools in China and elsewhere,
where kids are doing deliberate
visual focus exercises
in order to increase their mental focus.
And while they're not doing microdialysis
or brain imaging on
those kids in real time,
the cognitive effects and
indeed the performance effects
in terms of academic ability and output
are pretty impressive.
So acetylcholine increases focus.
We talked about some dietary
and some supplementation-based ways
to improve acetylcholine,
or I should say increase acetylcholine.
And that does in fact lead to increases
in one's ability to focus.
This is why a lot of
the prescription drugs
for the treatment
of Alzheimer's age-related
cognitive decline
and indeed, even some of the drugs
that tap into treatments for ADHD
also involve the acetylcholine system.
So there's nothing
surprising or heretical here,
but it is important to point out
that your behavioral ability to focus
is also related to your ability to access
and deploy acetylcholine.
So never do we want purely
pharmacologic treatments
to be the only way that
people are increasing
a given neuromodulator.
I always say behaviors first,
then nutrition,
then supplementation.
And then if there's a need,
certainly a clinical need,
then prescription drugs,
et cetera, of course
administered through a physician.
So let's discuss serotonin.
Serotonin, as I mentioned earlier,
is associated with brain and
body states of well-being,
of comfort, of satiety,
and therefore should come as no surprise
that a lot of the
prescription drug treatments
for things like depression
involve increasing levels of serotonin
in the brain and body.
That said, anytime you talk about
prescription drugs for serotonin,
we also want to acknowledge that
there are often side effects associated
with increasing serotonin,
in particular, if serotonin
levels go too high,
that is if the dosages of
those treatments go too high,
people will, for instance,
feel reduced appetite, reduced libido,
increased lethargy, et cetera.
And there's a so-called
serotonergic syndrome.
All of that can and should be considered
with a well-trained physician,
so because they're prescription drugs,
controlling the dosage,
deciding what dosage to take,
deciding which SSRI to take
and whether or not to
come off those drugs,
how to come off those drugs.
Again, all of that should be handled
with a licensed physician.
That said, there are behavioral
tools, nutritional tools,
and supplementation tools
that can tap into the serotonin system,
not to the same degree in potency,
but nonetheless, in ways
that can still impact
our feelings of well-being
in positive ways.
So let's focus first
on the behavioral tools
and some of these might make
people chuckle a little bit,
but I want to point out
that a lot of these tools
are quite potent.
In fact, they are power tools
for modulating serotonin.
And we know that based on
human neuro imaging studies,
human and animal microdialysis studies
and other studies that
really have evaluated
circulating levels of serotonin
and the particular brain
circuits that release serotonin
when people do certain things.
What sorts of things?
Well, for instance, physical contact,
in particular with loved ones,
this can be romantic love.
This can be children, so your own children
or your spouse, even if
it's not sexual contact,
friend to friend contact,
even friend to animal contact, you know,
as a former dog owner,
I hope to have another dog soon
'cause unfortunately Costello passed away,
but there is something really comforting
and wonderful about petting your dog.
And certainly, given that many
of the studies on serotonin
and these other neuromodulators
were done on animal models,
we also know that serotonin
is being evoked in the dog
and of course in the child
and in the significant other, et cetera.
So things like holding
hands, believe it or not,
hugs, cuddling, et cetera,
can increase serotonin transmission
and they make people feel good.
This shouldn't really come as a surprise.
There's also gratitude.
And we did an entire
episode about gratitude.
There's a lot of
misunderstanding about gratitude.
Oftentimes when people
hear gratitude, they think,
oh, gratitude, this is just being thankful
for what you have and it's
kind of a weak sauce effect,
meaning, you know, it's kind of like,
maybe a little serotonin goes up
or maybe there's a little bit
of increased feelings of well-being.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
It turns out, first of all,
that receiving not giving gratitude
is what has the most potent effects
on increasing serotonin and
activity of the brain circuits
that involve serotonin
and that lead to increases
in feelings of well-being.
So this is interesting.
Receiving much more than giving gratitude
is what activates those
serotonergic pathways.
So the takeaway from that is
both give and receive gratitude
and of course, do it in an authentic way.
The other thing about gratitude
that's somewhat counterintuitive is that
observing others giving
and receiving gratitude
is immensely powerful
for evoking serotonin
and the activity of
serotonergic circuits in you,
the observer.
So receiving and observing gratitude
turns out to be the most potent
way to increase serotonin
in the brain and body.
And these again are dramatic effects
that are quite long-lasting
and not the sorts of effects
that are going to lead to side effects,
at least there's no reason
to think they would.
Now what about nutritional approaches
to increasing serotonin?
Well, just as we have tyrosine
as an amino acid precursor
upstream of dopamine synthesis,
we have the amino acid tryptophan,
which is upstream of serotonin synthesis.
And one simply has to go online
and put in tryptophan containing foods
and you will discover that
there are a lot of foods
that are enriched in tryptophan
that can lead to net increases
in the amount of serotonin
available in the brain and body.
The most kind of famous
or infamous of these
is white meat turkey,
the so-called tryptophan effect
where people get very sleepy
after eating white meat turkey.
And it is indeed highly
enriched in tryptophan
although typically the getting
sleepy after eating turkey
is most often associated
with the Thanksgiving meal
and the Thanksgiving
meal, at least in the US,
is often associated with
people vastly overeating.
And so I do want to point out
that if you fill your gut with food,
no matter what that food is,
there's going to be a
diversion of blood to your gut
that's going to make you feel sleepy
because there's a diversion of blood
away from other tissues.
So if you eat a lot, you're
going to get sleepy, period,
whether or not you eat turkey
or some other substance.
Nonetheless, there are a number of foods
that contain a lot of tryptophan
and that some people will leverage
in order to try and
increase the total amount
of circulating serotonin available to them
in order to have a modest increase
in overall mood and well-being.
So what are some of these foods?
These are things like milk,
in particular, whole milk,
so full fat milk.
I know a number of people
choose not to drink milk
'cause they're lactose intolerant.
I'm raising my hand 'cause
I'm one such person,
although when I was a
kid, I did enjoy milk.
Canned tuna.
Turkey, as we mentioned
before, high in tryptophan.
Oats, I am a consumer of oatmeal
so that resonates with me.
Cheese and here I read,
although not as high in tryptophan as meat
and other dairy sources,
certain cheeses like cheddar cheeses
can be rich in tryptophan.
Certain nuts and seeds, certain breads.
Chocolate, I know a number of people
will be relieved to hear that.
I know chocolate lovers are always looking
for an excuse to eat chocolate.
I confess I've never
really liked chocolate,
except dare I say,
I like the smooth 100% percent chocolates.
I know many people gag when
they hear a hundred percent,
but I actually really like them.
And some fruits can be highly
enriched in tryptophan,
things like bananas and apples
and things of that sort,
although not nearly to
the degree of things
like turkey, canned tuna and milk.
I'm sure there are other
excellent sources of tryptophan
from the diet, including vegan sources
so please peruse the internet to try
and find the sources that are compatible
with your nutritional program,
if indeed your goal is
to increase tryptophan.
Now there are supplements
that can increase tryptophan
and can do so quite potently.
One of the ones that has
received increasing attention
as of lately is cissus quadrangularis,
complicated name,
when taken in dosages of
about 300 to 600 milligrams
can pretty dramatically
increase serotonin levels.
In fact, anywhere from
30% to 39% increases
in circulating serotonin.
That's a big increase
and I can provide a link to that study.
The study was focused,
not so much on serotonin,
but was focused mainly
on treatment of obesity
and appetite and weight loss.
And it should come as no
surprise that serotonin,
if increased, might lead
to decreases in appetite.
A cautionary note,
cissus quadrangularis
may need to be cycled.
How quickly to cycle it,
meaning do you do two
weeks on, two weeks off?
Whether or not you need
to do more rapid cycling
like two days on, two days
off, is a matter of debate.
There are not a lot of
data on this just yet.
There are a lot of opinions
about this on the internet,
but again, not a lot of
quality peer review data.
Nonetheless cissus
quadrangularis has been shown
to increase serotonin in humans
and for people that are
seeking to increase serotonin
maybe in particular,
for sake of appetite and weight control,
that might be a useful compound.
I know many people also take 5-HTP,
one of the precursors to serotonin
in dosages of anywhere
from 300 to 500 milligrams.
Typically people are doing
this in anticipation of sleep,
meaning in the final hour of wakefulness
before going to sleep.
I myself have tried 5-HTP prior to sleep
and all I can tell you is
that it led to very deep sleep
for about one to three hours.
And then I woke up and I
could not fall back asleep.
I ran that experiment twice
before I decided to abandon
5-HTP as a sleep aid.
And that's why I've never
put it into our sleep kit
or at least my sleep kit.
And when I refer to the sleep kit,
that's something you can
find at HubermanLab.com.
This is zero cost resource
where you can see behavioral tools
and also supplementation tools
that can improve the transition time
into and the depth of sleep.
And none of those rely
on 5-HTP supplementation.
That said,
I know a number of people
use 5-HTP supplementation
outside of sleep,
or I should say during the daytime
to try and increase serotonin
and it will indeed increase
circulating serotonin.
But again, people vary
in their sensitivity
to these sorts of things.
Some people might find for instance,
that 300 milligrams of
5-HTP is just far too much.
It blunts their appetite,
might even reduce libido.
There aren't a lot of very
well controlled studies
looking at this
and so it has to be figured
out on an individual basis,
if you decide to approach it at all.
Now one molecule that I've found
to be particularly interesting and useful
and this is one that I
haven't talked about yet
on this podcast
is inositol, in particular myo-inositol.
Myo-inositol can have the
effect of increasing serotonin
and other neurochemicals,
but primarily at least in terms
of the neuromodulators
discussed today, serotonin.
I've been taking 900
milligrams of myo-inositol
every third night or so
as a test of its ability to improve sleep.
And I have to say,
the depth and quality of
sleep that I've been obtaining
on myo-inositol is pretty remarkable.
In fact, I've used it alone
and in combination
with the magnesium threonate,
apigenin, theanine sleep kit
that I've talked about and
that's included in that,
again, zero cost kit that's available
as a PDF on our website.
So myo-inositol is known
to increase circulating
levels of serotonin.
It has been explored extensively
in both animal models and in humans
for its daytime use for treating anxiety.
It does seem to reduce anxiety.
And for all sorts of things.
It's been explored for bipolar disorder.
We're going to do an episode
about bipolar disorder coming up.
It's been explored for
the treatment of migraine.
It's been explored for ADHD.
It's been explored for a huge number
of different conditions of brain and body.
Again, I've been using the 900 milligrams
of myo-inositol in the 30
to 60 minutes before sleep
to improve my sleep
and it has been doing
that very dramatically,
especially when I take it alongside
the rest of those sleep kit supplements.
A quick note about myo-inositol
for sake of increasing serotonin.
if you look at the human
studies on myo-inositol
that are out there
and in particular focus
on the human studies,
what you'll find is that the
dosages that are often used
are tremendously high,
things like five grams,
eight grams, 18 grams of myo-inositol
taken throughout the day.
I don't know how people stomach that.
And in fact, many people
drop out of those studies
because of gastric discomfort.
And yet I also wonder
how people tolerate it
because it has somewhat
of a sedative effect
and this kind of anti-anxiety effect.
And I can't even imagine
given my experience with 900 milligrams,
what one would experience taking multiple
or many more grams per day.
So I certainly am not encouraging that.
And the only reason I mention myo-inositol
is that it has a known effect
of increasing serotonin.
At least in my experience,
it does not lead to this
falling deeply asleep
and waking back up.
Actually to the contrary,
if I wake up in the middle of
the night to use the bathroom,
or I wake up at the middle of the night,
for whatever other reason,
I find it far easier to fall back asleep
if I've taken 900 milligrams
myo-inositol prior to sleep.
So for me, it's proving to
be a quite useful compound.
I'm not aware of having any
serotonergic deficiency overall.
I don't consider myself depressed.
And of course I should
mention that no supplement
either added or withdrawn
from your protocol
should ever be used as
a direct replacement
for prescription drug treatments
that your physician has given you.
You should always talk to your physician
anytime you remove or add
something to your drug protocol
or prescription protocol, of course.
So we've got behavioral protocols
that as silly as it feels to say,
have been shown to potently
increase serotonin,
things like physical contact, cuddling,
holding hands with people that
you love, of course, right?
I think if they were
people that you despise,
it would have the opposite
effect for obvious reasons.
But also receiving gratitude
and observing gratitude,
very potent increases in serotonin
and things like cissus quadrangularis,
things like 5-HGP may
have their uses, right?
They're very potent at
increasing serotonin,
but they do seem to have
the need to cycle them
and they are nuanced.
Some people respond well to them,
others like myself don't
and of course, always be
on the lookout for dramatic
or even subtle decreases in appetite
or libido or things
that you might not want
if you are going to be tinkering
with your serotonergic
levels and pathways.
And then myo-inositol actually
is proving to be quite useful to me
and whether or not that's
because of its effects on serotonin
or through some of its other effects on
maybe reducing anxiety,
which certainly I experience
if I wake up in the middle of the night,
I don't like waking up in
the middle of the night,
but on myo-inositol,
I sort of seem to not
really care that I woke up
and I fall right back asleep.
So the direct source
of the positive effects
that I'm getting aren't
clear, but nonetheless,
I thought I'd pass it
along as a useful tool
because it is out there
and it is available over the counter
and provided you're taking
the appropriate safety steps
in considering whether
or not to use it or not,
I think it might be a useful tool.
And of course,
as with all the other
neuromodulators we discussed,
you have both a baseline of serotonin
and the ability to give
or provide yourself peaks of serotonin
through these various protocols.
The dietary interventions of
the sort that I mentioned,
meaning eating foods that
are enriched in tryptophan,
those are mainly going to
adjust your baseline levels of tryptophan.
For instance, if you
really want to be sleepy,
sure you could eat some white meat turkey
in hopes that that tryptophan
will convert to serotonin
and make you sleepy, et cetera.
But in general,
those are going to be
pretty long-lasting effects,
especially given the fact that not all
of the tryptophan you will ingest
is going to be converted
into serotonin in your brain.
It's going to have other effects
on other tissues and organs of your body.
Nonetheless, if you want
to increase serotonin,
providing the appropriate baseline context
is going to be useful.
And again, this is a general theme
of all four of these neuromodulators,
dopamine, epinephrine,
acetylcholine and serotonin.
You want to make sure that you have
sufficient baseline levels of those things
through things like
diet, regular behaviors,
and then you have the opportunity
to use supplementation
and if it's appropriate for
you, prescription drugs,
and certain behavioral protocols
to try and get these potent increases,
these acute increases in
whichever the neuromodulators
you happen to want to leverage
for your particular goals.
So that brings us to the end
of at least this exploration
of the neuromodulators,
dopamine, epinephrine,
acetylcholine and serotonin.
Some of you who are regular
listeners of this podcast
might be saying, well, we've
heard all this before, right?
You had an episode on dopamine.
You had an episode on anxiety.
You had an episode on sleep.
And indeed that's true.
But what I've tried to provide today
is a framework that cuts
through all those episodes
and at the same time builds out a new
and what I believe to be
a really important theme and principle,
which is that whether or not
you're using nutritional tools
or supplementation or prescription drugs
or any other sort of protocol
to try and create a
desired effect of focus
or energy, motivation, relaxation,
you are playing with the same
neurochemical ingredients,
just as in the realm of nutrition,
you have macronutrients,
you have proteins, carbohydrates, and fats
that can be adjusted in different ratios
and arranged at different times
in order to achieve
certain desired effects.
Well, when it comes to your neurochemistry
and your ability to perform
mentally, to perform physically,
and your overall well-being,
you are dealing with a small handful
of especially potent molecules.
And I acknowledge that there
are many neuromodulators.
There are indeed many neurotransmitters,
glutamine, glycine, GABA, et cetera.
But today we focused on the main four,
meaning the most potent
and most widespread neuromodulators
in the brain and body
that give you access to
particular brain states
and body states of the sort
that most people desire.
So what I'm hoping is that
rather than decide that any
one tool is the most useful
or that any one neurochemical
is most useful for that matter,
that the information
that I've provided today
allows you a kit of versatile tools
that allows you to figure out
what levels of dopamine and
augmentation of dopamine
are appropriate and necessary for you.
What levels of acetylcholine
and tools for manipulating acetylcholine
are going to be most useful for you
and so on and so forth
because at least at this stage in time,
that is June, 2022,
there is no simple at home test.
In fact, there is no
simple laboratory test
that allows us to know whether or not
our dopamine levels are high
and our serotonin levels are low.
We can look at somebody
and their behavior.
We can look at ourselves and
our own mood and behavior.
And we can infer what those
levels may or may not be.
But unfortunately, we don't
have a really good test
of dopamine levels or serotonin levels
that would allow us to say,
okay, this person, or I need
to increase dopamine two-fold
in order to achieve the kind
of motivation that we want.
Unfortunately, that doesn't exist.
Rather, we are confronted with a situation
where we understand
generally what these
different neuromodulators do,
the different mental
states and physical states
that they tend to put us into.
And we reviewed those.
And we know that there
are really potent tools
to adjust those neuromodulators,
if not alone, but in certain combinations,
that is ingestion of
caffeine will tap into
and support dopamine and epinephrine.
Increasing dopamine and epinephrine
alongside increasing acetylcholine
will allow us to access
certain brain states,
that is focused, alert,
energized, brain states,
great for learning and
plasticity of all kinds.
Whereas augmenting
serotonin is going to put us
into a more relaxed state
and so on and so forth.
And I'd like you to keep in mind
that there is no negotiating
the fact that we all have different phases
of our 24-hour cycle
during which those very
same neuromodulators
tend to be naturally
higher or naturally lower
and I reviewed that at the
beginning of the episode.
So my wish for you is that you
will take this information,
experiment with it as you see
fit for you and in a safe way.
And as you go forward,
to really try and gain
intuition and understanding
as to not just how these protocols work,
but how any protocol
that you might encounter,
supplement-based, drug-based,
behavioral-based,
how those might tap into these different
major neuromodulator systems.
And from that, to be
able to better predict
and evaluate whether or not
they're going to be useful to you,
detrimental to you,
or whether or not they should
be used in combinations
that would be more useful to you.
If you're learning from and
are enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple
and on both Spotify and Apple,
you can leave us up to a five star review.
If you have feedback for us
or you have topics or guests
that you'd like us to cover
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please put that in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do eventually read all those comments
and that's the best place to
give us that sort of feedback.
In addition, please check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
of today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
During today's episode,
we talked a lot about supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them.
As mentioned at the
beginning of today's episode,
we partnered with Momentous supplements
because they're extremely high quality,
they ship internationally,
they are available in the dosages
and single ingredient formulations
that are ideal for building
a supplementation protocol.
You can find all those at
liveMomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
we are @hubermanlab on Twitter
and @hubermanlab on Instagram.
There, I cover science
and science-based tools,
some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is distinct
from the content of the
Huberman Lab Podcast.
And if you're not already
subscribing to our newsletter,
we have a Neural Network
Newsletter as it's called.
It comes out about once a month.
We provide summaries.
We provide protocols
based on podcast episodes.
All of that is zero cost to access.
You just go to Hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu,
click on newsletter, and you can sign up.
We do not share your email with anybody
and our privacy policy is there.
In fact, if you want to
see previous newsletters,
they are available
without having to sign up
in PDF form also at HubermanLab.com
under the newsletter tabs,
things like a toolkit for sleep
and a neuroplasticity super protocol,
all available as immediately
downloadable PDFs.
So I'd like to thank you once
again for joining me today
in our discussion about these
incredibly powerful molecules
we call neuromodulators
and the things we can do and take
in order to control them
so that we can enhance our
mental health, physical health
and performance.
And last, but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[upbeat music]